nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi maintenant provisoirement un
dispositif de veille et de sécurité
sanitaire en matière de luttre contre la
copie de 10,9 dans la discussion des
articles
nous sommes parvenus aux explications de
votes sur les amendements identiques
numéro 7 30 rectifié bis 38 rectifié bis
et 62 au sein de l'article 2 et nous
avons les explications de vote qui ont
été déjà demandé monsieur chasse un
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
voilà je m'exprime donc sur
effectivement les articles que vous avez
cités maintenant la présidente mais
aussi sur l'article 38 je n'ai pas pu le
faire tout à l'heure
donc je ne vois pas dans la demande de
tester à 12 ans de discriminations ou
d'hostilité vis-à-vis des jeunes les
jeunes ont très bien compris que
l'efficacité pour se préserver de la
contagion qui peut être trop massive et
emboliser l'hôpital et menacer
l'économie il ya certains virus non
comme le centaure qui paraît très
agressif ya beaucoup de descendants il
faut tester isolé tracé vacciner
vacciner pour éviter les formes graves
et diminuer la contagion ce ne sont pas
les tests qui coûte cher mais les
hospitalisations sur une critique henry
à 9 malade sur dix en soins critiques et
réanimation ne sont pas vaccinés ce sont
des faits ce ne sont pas des accidents
de la route transformer en covit comme
c'est écrit dans l'amendement de 38
allez voir les médecins urgentistes et
en réanimation
neuf sur dix ne sont pas vaccinés en réa
c'est aussi le cas actuel et abrite que
j'ai rencontré et donc il n'y a pas
beaucoup de personnages est en fait mais
des gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés est
joué vous vous dire aussi que avant la
vaccination
l'entrée en virus en ehpad était un
véritable cauchemar pour les médecins
les bien sûr les directeurs le choix
niant les soignants et les familles il
faut donc tester les jeunes à partir de
12 et la population pompe est débordée
en hôpital et conserver l'activité
économique merci si madame muller brawn
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre chers
collègues alors je reviens sur cette
idée de
de faire un test aux enfants à partir de
12 ans on aurait aimé et beaucoup de
parents beaucoup de structures scolaires
périscolaires de grands parents aurait
aimé éviter que les enfants entre 12 et
18 ans lorsqu'ils ne sont pas majeurs
soient soumis encore une fois à des
mesures qui qui sont oppressante qui
sont qui ne sont pas favorables à leur
équilibre je voudrais juste dire que le
sar sco vide 2 est ce une zone aux et
donc touche plus de 40 espèces animales
y compris les animaux domestiques alors
si nous voulons nous mettre sous cloche
que le virus très dangereux n'entre pas
par les adultes n'entre pas dans notre
pays par les enfants
que faisons-nous avec les animaux les
animaux domestiques
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que le
hamster importés du pays bas a été la
source établit d'une rude recrudescence
épidémique à hong kong une étude publiée
dans le lancet tu as mis en évidence la
diffusion du virus par les frontières
internationales via le commerce des
animaux et on sait que les containers
transportent des animaux de compagnie
malgré donc les passes et malgré la
vaccination humaine donc nous n'y
arriverons pas comment voulez vous faire
est ce qu'on doit créer un test aussi
pour que les animaux n'apporte pas le
virus très dangereux sur le territoire
national
merci monsieur benarroch
c'était juste une question au fait que
j'avais vous savez que nous avons déposé
un amendement dans ce sens là donc pour
faire en sorte que la maxi de le pass
voyage ne soit demandé qu'à partir de 18
ans et j'ai entendu une argumentation me
semble utile dans la bouche de monsieur
le ministre
faisant état en fait d'une sorte de taux
de contagiosité ou du nombre de
contagiosité qui était lié ou qui
étaient dues à des personnes entre 10 et
19 ans alors j'ai peut-être mal compris
d'abord je voulais avoir peut-être cette
précision est ce que parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est le château et d'où vient-il et
deuxièmement si c'est entre 10 et 10
devant je posais une question bête mais
je vais la poser à tout le monde
pourquoi ces 12 or et pourquoi c'est pas
dix ans donc à
part par l'absurde quoi en quelque sorte
voilà
merci monsieur juillet
merci madame la présidente il ya quelque
chose de juste dans ce que dit madame
noël notre collègue noël c'est que y'a
aucun dispositif qui permet à coup sûr
d'arrêter un virus à l'entrée sur un
territoire est-ce qu'on tire de ce
constat
la décision de ne rien faire c'est ce
que vous proposez et je suis encore une
fois étonné que sur les mêmes bancs ceux
qui réclamaient la fermeture totale des
frontières ce virus il vient de
l'étranger bla aujourd'hui adopte la
position inverse c'est à dire on ne fait
rien la question qui se pose à nous
c'est la question de la mailles du filet
pour essayer de retarder l'entrée
éventuelle d'un variant dangereux parce
qu'on est quand même dans l'hypothétique
et donc il ya une question qui est de
trancher et oui ça pourrait être dix ans
ça pourrait être 5 en sabre est donc là
la décision et les politiques on peut
décider de ne rien faire et de dire ses
18 ans même ou 20 ans ou 30 ans et là il
a été dit il est proposé 12 ans
c'est une maille qui me paraît
raisonnable est-ce que ça d effet
problématique j'ai entendu invoqué des
troubles psychologiques alors c'est une
question sérieuse ce qui a été l'impact
notamment des confinement
de la privation d'activités sociales
pour les enfants et pour les jeunes
pendant la première phase de la pandémie
mais pardon ne transpose on passa sur le
fait de réaliser un test parce qu'on va
prendre l'avion pour aller à new york ou
pour revenir de 20 départements
d'outre-mer non franchement invoqué la
un trouble psychologique chez les
enfants ou une mesure disproportionnée
j'ai entendu aussi le thème me paraît
pas très recevable donc ce qui est
proposé la l'âge de 12 ans et
raisonnable with discute si vous aviez
déposé un amendement disant je ne sais
pas pourquoi pas mais en tout état de
cause je ne vois pas d'arguments sérieux
pour voter ces amendements qui
consisterait à relâcher les mailles du
filet merci chers collègues madame goy
chavent
la présidente merci
pourquoi 12 ans en fait moi ça me paraît
je suis pas une grande spécialiste mais
un peu au doigt mouillé on parle de
justement monsieur daumier bien de dire
dix ans ben tiens pourquoi pas neuf
pourquoi pas de 13
pourquoi pas 14 failles à un moment oui
on souffle pourquoi pas deux ans met fin
à un moment je crois que bornons nous à
ce qui avait été voté ce qui avait été
proposé à l'assemblée nationale pour
quoi faire plus strictes plus invasif
parce que certains enfants à 12 ans
vivent très mal le test pcr dans le
néant je peux vous le dire autant
peut-être à 17-18 ans après ce but
évidemment vous n'avez que des enfants
parfaits j'imagine qu'ils supportent
tout en attendant moi j'ai des retours
de personnes qui me disent oh la la les
tests vous savez ils sont pas fait tout
le temps de la même manière ils sont pas
toujours fait de manière très douce et
parfois c'est un petit peu difficile à
vivre pour les enfants donc voilà c'est
juste une question moi je pose la
question pourquoi 12 ans pourquoi
revenir sur une disposition qui
finalement était très logique parce que
18 ans et finalement la majorité et je
trouve que c'est assez logique
personnellement je voterai ces
amendements
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
ces quatre amendements identiques donc
le 7 le 30 rectifier le 38 rectifier le
62 qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adopté deux
amendements identiques dans l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 55 présentée
par monsieur bonnecarrère
vous avez tous écouté la présente vous
avez tous écouté la présentation de
notre à porter l'article 2 est divisé en
deux parties une partie qui concerne les
transports internationaux une partie 2
qui concerne les transports entre la
corse les outre mer et la métropole la
partie une les transports internationaux
et dans l'esprit de notre rapporteur
traité sur la base de l'apparition de
varia le gouvernement pourrait en cas
d'apparition dans variant quelque part
dans le monde reprendre des dispositions
dites de filtrage pour reprendre la
formulation qui a été utilisée tout à
l'heure pour la relation avec
l'outre-mer et la corse la logique est
différente elle s'appuie exclusivement
sur l'idée de ne pas créer de situations
sur charge hospitalière outre mer cette
seconde logique a conduit notre
rapporteur a une vraie d'action dans
lequel il prévoit que seuls les trajets
entre la métropole et outre-mer ou la
corse pourrait faire l'objet de mesures
préventives de la part du gouvernement
c'est rationnel puisque c'est la logique
à partir laquelle il a construit sa
rédaction le seul problème que nous
n'avons pas vu immédiatement
c'est que chacun sait vous avez par
exemple les mouvements de population
réguliers entre le brésil et la guyane
vous pouvez en avoir entre les hauts
plateaux africa et et mayotte entre
autres exemples si demain vous avez un
virus qui vint variant qui apparaît au
brésil vous pourrez assurer une
filtration entre recife où rio de
janeiro et paris mais vous ne pourrez
pas le faire entre la guyane et paris
donc la rédaction cet amendement vise à
permettre de corriger ce trou dans le
filet pour reprendre une formulation qui
a été utilisée également dans la
situation du trajet dans le sens retour
j'ajoute que la commission des lois a eu
un regard favorable sur cet amendement
qui dont la rédaction est alignée sur
celle de mes collègues qui vante
intervenir le rédaction ils ont été plus
complète merci merci l'amendement 65
donc identiques présentés par monsieur
mohamed faye
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les motifs
de notre amendement viennent d'être
exprimée avec l' art et vin notre
collègue philippe bonnecarrère je veux
rappeler que cet amendement est en
cohérence avec l'article approuvé en
commission un amendement de protection
du territoire contre les variants qui
sont susceptibles de circuler à
l'étranger dans des pays limitrophes
faut-il rappeler le cheminement des
variants bêta et delta lesquels ont eu
un rôle actif dans de précédentes vagues
je veux bien insister ici sur les points
suivants tout d'abord au terme de cet
amendement les conditions et critères
d'application du certificat au
déplacement depuis les outre-mer sont
resserrés par rapport au droit en
vigueur ensuite l'amendement conserve
plusieurs modifications intervenues lors
des débats à l'assemblée nationale puis
lors de l'examen en commission au sénat
s'agissant de l'application du
certificat pour les déplacements à
destination des outre-mer notre
amendement prévoit d'ailleurs lui-même
la consultation des exécutifs locaux et
des parlementaires des collectivités
d'outre-mer prosternés en amont d'une
application du certificat pour les
déplacements depuis les outre-mer enfin
ces dispositions consiste seulement dans
une faculté que le gouvernement ne
pourrait mettre en oeuvre que jusqu'au
31 janvier 2023 au plus tard dans
l'intérêt de la santé publique et aux
seules fins de lutter contre la
propagation de l'épidémie de covile 19
de manière strictement proportionnées
aux risques sanitaires encourus et
appropriée aux circonstances de temps et
de lieu et qu'il devra cesser
d'appliquer sans délai lorsqu'elle n'est
plus nécessaire je cite ici la loi je
remercie ainsi l'avis de la commission
celle rapporteur
l'avis est favorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mais a démissionné les sénateurs le
caractère insulaire de la plupart des
outre-mer est la proximité de pays
étrangers connaissent en situation
sanitaire très diverses qui ont
effectivement donné lieu à l'apparition
de nouveaux variants brésil afrique du
sud nécessite de permettre l'application
de la mesure aux voyageurs en provenance
d outre-mer à destination de l'hexagone
pour éviter une plus forte diffusion du
virus le caractère très touristique de
ces tours histoire et les brassages
particuliers auxquels ils sont exposés
sont également à prendre en compte à cet
égard en outre la symétrie que vous
souhaitez instauré entre l'hexagone et
d'outre-mer existe dans notre droit
depuis l'introduction du pass-foncier
hier sans que cela ait soulevé de
difficultés particulières auparavant
votre amendement d'indiens maintient à 6
déséquilibres existants et on sait que
la mesure est utile vers l'hexagone
comme entre territoires ultramarins pour
limiter la diffusion de nouveaux
variants apparu à l'étranger qui
entrerait sur le territoire par les
outre-mer dans tous les cas je rappelle
que vous ne votez pas qu une
habilitation instauré le pass variant
lors des déplacements depuis les
outre-mer à destination de l'hexagone
elle ne sera mis en oeuvre par la
première ministre que si nécessaire
enfin d'amendements prévoir la
consultation des exécutifs et
parlementaires concernées avant toute
application du dispositif
garantissant une décision concertée avec
les populations ultramarines ce que je
ne peux qu'approuver pour ces raisons
avis favorable
merci
alors oui mais certains noms
merci madame la présidente parce
qu'autant autant le texte de la
commission modifié proposé par le
rapporteur m'allait très bien
sur la protection de nos territoires
notamment en cas de saturation du
système hospitalier autant le message
qu'on envoie aujourd'hui aux français
d'outre-mer c'est que quand vous partez
de la bretagne pour la paris on peut
vous demander impasse c'est exactement
le même message que vous voulez
d'envoyer ces cons vous venez d'un
territoire ultramarin de saint pierre et
miquelon pour aller vers l'hexagone on
peut exiger à un moment donné la preuve
que vous ne soyez pas atteint de kovy d'
allah vous me direz c'est une
possibilité monsieur le ministre je vous
ai entendu effectivement moi je parle du
symbole et du message qu'on envoie aux
territoires
si certains ici n'ont pas encore compris
que le résultat des élections on a connu
cette année avait été impacté et orthez
complètement par la manière dont la
crise sanitaire avait été gérée sur
certaines mesures qui n'ont pas été
prises écoutez par les exécutifs locaux
et merci monsieur le rapporteur d'avoir
intégré les exécutifs au niveau de la
vie donnée par le représentant de l'état
sur les mesures envisagées je pense
qu'on n'a pas encore compris le message
qui est envoyé à nos ultras marins et
c'est vrai que le vrai message intégré
dans thèse de la commission c'est une
protection parce que le vrai sujet pour
nous c'est la pénétration du virus sur
notre territoire
pour éviter le risque de saturation et
ce n'est pas l'un vers ce même si
effectivement le semis sa du brassage
chacun dans nos bassins géographiques
c'est pas vraiment là le sujet
d'ailleurs il suffit d'observer le
décalage dans le temps de la crise
sanitaire en outre-mer par rapport à
l'hexagone je pense que c'est simplement
faire preuve de pragmatisme et moi
sincèrement et je les dis à mes
collègues je m'opposerai à ces deux
amendements qui sont de mon point de vue
un mauvais message envoyé aux outre-mer
on voyait à tous les français parce que
quand vous partez d'un vol direct
ultramarins vers l'hexagone on peut vous
demander une preuve de la même manière
que celle qu'on peut exiger à l'entrée
sur le territoire français mais on est
en france mais peut-être qu'il faut
encore le rappeler visiblement et ça
n'est semble-t-il pas tout à fait
claires sur merci merci monsieur lurel
madame la présidente je vais midi chez
un collègue je partage totalement l'avis
de mon collègue martin est totalement
parce que le message est envoyé là c'est
de dire que si deux mais il devait y
avoir une circulation encore plus
intensive du virus il peut être importé
des autres mais on est en train de le
créer la mesure de frontières virtuelles
que je ne comprends pas et je peux
entendre voir comprendre le sens de
l'amendement mais je peux pas
l'approuver de dire que en fait pour
résumer ça il y à symétrie ce que l'on
demande au départ de la métropole eh
bien on va l'exigé aussi au départ de
aujourd'hui vous sent ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de
changer un système qui fonctionne le
mieux pratiquement deux ans alors je ne
comprends pas à quel est le motif même
le rapporte qui porte un fin et subtil
juriste n'a pas osé demander ça c'est
vous qui demandez ça en ostracisant
davantage mots que j'aime pas mais que
je vais utiliser les autres mais je vais
voter contre ces deux amendements
merci oui mais ces patients
est beau je voulais aussi qu'on fait
donc tout simplement pour dire que je
voudrais passer deux amendements
oui madame la présidente
mes chers collègues tout ce qui est
excessif est vain je viens d'entendre
parler de strass isation je viens
d'entendre parler d'un message qui ne
serait pas passé souvenez-vous lorsque
cette pandémie a commencé nous étions
les premiers à notre mère a demandé la
protection de nos territoires a demandé
de la solidarité cet amendement c'est de
la solidarité parce que nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter de demander de la
solidarité et qu'il y ait des mesures de
protection et de contrôle au départ de
la métropole et
à partir de nos territoires nous ont
lavé les mains alors que nous savons que
des variants comme le 501 qui est né en
afrique du sud et bien a fini par gagner
le monde entier l'afrique du sud c'est
un territoire qui se trouve pas loin de
mayotte pour venir pour partir de
l'afrique du sud à mayotte il y à un
moyen très simple
on va aux comores
et puis des comores à mayotte vous savez
c'est une passoire nous passons notre
temps à le dire ici de la même manière
du brésil ou en guyane est ce qu'il
faudrait taire cette situation juste
parce qu'on n'est pas en train de parler
d'immigration clandestine et bien moi je
suis désolé c'est une solidarité que je
dois à mes collègues de l'hexagone
n'importe qui à n'importe quel moment
peut passer de l'afrique du sud à
mayotte du jour au lendemain et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que le variant 500
et a commencé à inquiéter parce que
connue en afrique du sud eh bien on la
détecte et aux comores donc moi c'est la
raison d'être de ces temps et seulement
17 amendements je pourrais dire on est
protégé en partant de l'hexagone on est
tranquille mais je pense que le variant
de partir aussi de nos territoires vers
l'hexagone merci chers collègues même
jasmin
je voudrais dire tout simplement qu'il
faudrait qu'on soit un moment donné
cohérent
tantôt on parle de continuité
territoriale
alors il faudrait qu'on sache ce qu'on
veut vraiment merci
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix
c'est deux amendements donc que 55 et 65
qui ont reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui pour
qui est contre
les comptes
c'est contre
écoutez on va vous demander un assis
debout je suis désolé ça va vous faire
bouger vos endormir et moi
qui est pour
qui est contre
oui
qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés
je vous remercie
cet amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 40 monsieur le
comte
si madame la présidente monsieur me lis
mes chers collègues nous avons déposé
cet amendement parce que nous avons été
stupéfaits
du texte que le
rapporteur a fait adopter par la
commission des lois texte qui supprime
l'obligation
finalement 2 1 qui qui fait une croix
sur le pass sanitaires pour appuyer la
sécurité sanitaire du pays exclusivement
sur les tests pcr
que recherche le cauchemar que tous s'y
lie à la menace d'un nouveau variant de
protéger au maximum
le territoire nous savons depuis deux
ans qu'aucune mesure de protection aux
frontières n'est totalement étanche au
mieux aux frênes l'on freine
suffisamment tôt mieux connaître le
variant
et on a vu comment on pouvait y parvenir
avec la combinaison de tests pcr de la
vaccination ou des certificats de
rétablissement pourquoi après deux ans
reviendrait ton au fameux test pcr d'il
ya deux ans monsieur le rapporteur c'est
assez problématique c'est aussi assez
problématique par rapport à ce que vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure sur le
respect du droit européen le certificat
vert union européenne il dit bien
mobilité pour ceux qui ont un test pcr
ou bien un certificat de rétablissement
ou bien un certificat de vaccination
donc c'est assez étonnant que maintenant
vous nous fassiez le contraire j'ajoute
que
aucun
la vaccination et permet d'être permet
de diminuer les risques de contamination
quand on regarde les tests un rapport
d'à peu près à 8,1 à 1,9 donc être
vaccinés permettent d'être moins
finalement contagieux
j'ajoute aussi que toute mesure qui
qui freine et s'il ya des tests les
tests pcr ne sont en rien une garantie
si invariants qui galope parce que si
invariants qui galope et qui menacent
vous demandez aux gens de faire des
tests vous les relâcher dans la nature
pour 1 en 48 heures avant qu'ils
voyagent ils peuvent choper le variant
et après vous les ferez vite venir de
toute façon c'est pas certain et en plus
parmi les nouveaux variants il peut y en
avoir qui ne sont pas visibles par les
tests pcr sinon ça fait que nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons rétablir le
nex tel qu'il était auparavant comme
nos collègues merci monsieur le comte
l'amendement numéro 19 madame uleb brawn
merci madame la présidente alors c'est
un amendement qui prévoit que la durée
de validité des examens de dépistage
virologique soit inscrite dans la loi
est ainsi conforme au certificat
européen
ceci est indispensable pour éviter que
le gouvernement n'impose par décret une
durée réduite à 24 heures comme il l'a
fait le 25 novembre dernier ce qui avait
mis d'ailleurs en difficulté de nombreux
français tant dans leurs déplacements
ainsi que dans leur vie quotidienne et
ce sans preuve scientifique de son
efficacité merci merci alors quatre
amendements identiques puisque le 67 a
été retiré donc le 6 à monsieur
benachenhou
oui madame la présidente merci c'est le
même amendement que celui défendu par
monsieur le comte
pourquoi je vais essayer de développer
deux autres arguments le premier c'est
que la mesure contraignante de présenter
un test de dépistage sont négatifs et
que celui ci nécessiterait en fait
parallèlement la gratuité de ces tests
pour garantir à tous citoyens grands
marins corses et citoyens de l'hexagone
la libre circulation sur notre
territoire or il est nullement envisagé
de rock gratuit ces tests de dépistage
pour les personnes non vaccinées à moins
que monsieur le ministre ici présents ne
soit venu faire des annonces en ce sens
il nous le dira deuxième argument aussi
c'est celui de la cohérence de nos
politiques
la position du rapporteur philippe bas
de restreindre l'accès des patients à la
seule condition de présentation de tests
de dépistage semble ajouter nous
semble-t-il de la confusion aux messages
de prévention est politique vaccinale
adressé aux français depuis ces
dernières années ces derniers ont joué
lieu puisque au 17 juillet 2022 80% des
français avaient bénéficié d'un schéma
vaccinal complet ils sortent donc dès
lors très curieux d'envoyer un message
politique contraire à leurs épouses en
maître l'her à nouveau la réalisation de
tests pour leurs déplacements
j'oserais dire d'ailleurs j'en serais
rappelé que nous avions été les premiers
ici même à ouvrir le débat sur la
troisième dose afin de faire de schéma
vaccinal complet une véritable
protection pour la population enfin je
rappellerai qu'il n'est pas justifié sur
un plan sanitaire d'exclure de
certificats de rétablissement de lakovic
19 des modifie des modalités de
certificats sanitaires de voyage dès
lors qu'il est établi que ces personnes
récemment contaminées et guéris ne
présente pas de risque de contamination
dans l'immédiat je ne vous ferai pas
l'affront de ressortir les
argumentations du ministre de la santé
précédent qui lui même était réticent la
présentation d'une preuve de non
contamination par test
les restrictions de libertés
fondamentales et un cloud la liberté
d'aller et venir doivent être justifiée
par un motif d'intérêt général et
doivent être également nécessaire et
proportionnée les auteurs du présent
amendement ne considère pas que ces
conditions soient réunies en l'espèce
ceux-là modifications que nous proposons
ainsi qu'un certain nombre de nos
collègues
merci le 36 monsieur chasse sans
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur rapporté aux seuls
présidents donc si vous voulez c'est
expliquer tout à l'heure par
l'amendement socialiste le présent
amendement a donc pour objet de rétablir
la faculté pour les voyageurs de se
présenter l'un des trois documents que
constituait le pass sanitaires c'est à
dire effectivement le test statut
vaccinal ou certificat de rétablissement
alors effectivement le
l'argument selon lequel seul un test
négatif pourrait empêcher la propagation
du virus c'est efficace mais le vaccin
est aussi efficace mais pas 100% parce
que sur le faire un test il faudrait
leur faire après une quarantaine
mais bon par ailleurs il apparaît
primordial de continuer à encourager la
population à se faire vacciner
à l'heure où la quatrième dose de vaccin
est ouverte aux personnes les plus
vulnérables
enfin surtout ça a été dit cette
disposition ne sommes pas conforme à
l'esprit du règlement européen
selon l'article 3 du point 7 dispose
ainsi que la délivrance des certificats
en vertu du paragraphe 1 du présent
article ne peut entraîner discrimination
fondée sur la possession d'une catégorie
spécifique de certificats mais l article
5 certificat de vaccination de tests
certificat de rétablissement donc
c'était dans un but de cohérence qui
paraissait important
puisque s'ils voulaient séparer à
l'encontre de ce qui se passe au niveau
européen il paraît important de
maintenir ouverte la possibilité pour
les voyageurs de présenter l'un des
trois documents constituant le
certificat covit numérique de lieux
merci le 54 me bonnecarrère
oui nous sommes là sur le seul sujet qui
fâche notre groupe et que nous n'avions
pas du tout imaginé que nous n'avions
pas vu arriver
si les amendements que nous présentons
ne sont pas adoptées cela veut dire que
demain en situation de crise
seul peut être rétabli
l'obligation passer un certificat de pas
se faire tester pour pouvoir se déplacer
regardons demain regardons le passé si
on regarde demain
à partir du moment où il n'y a plus
aucune disposition qui donne une
pertinence une conséquence au fait
d'être vaccinés cela veut dire que vous
avez officiellement considéré que le
certificat de vaccination n'a aucun
intérêt et derrière nos concitoyens ne
peuvent que comprendre que si le
certificat de vaccination n'a pas
d'intérêt la vaccination n'a pas même
d'intérêt c'est toute la contradiction
pour demain vous avez quasiment tous dit
sur les différents bancs que l'on avait
besoin de la vaccination plus que jamais
pour assurer la protection collective
nos concitoyens et là on adopterait une
mesure si vous ne nous suivait pas qui
va à l'encontre de la vaccination et si
maintenant vous regardez le passé et je
fais quand même appel à la cohérence des
positions qui ont été défendues par
philippe bas et par le président
retailleau peu de votre groupe depuis le
début vous avez pris une logique à
laquelle il faut rendre hommage de
vouloir protéger les populations vous
avez donc voté les différents textes
malgré les difficultés que cela
représentait pour chacun de nous sur les
passes sanitaires si demain
officiellement on dit que le certificat
de vaccination n'a pas le même intérêt
que le test cela revient à dire que
pendant deux ans nous avons imposé à nos
concitoyens des choses qui ne seraient
pas justifiées
vous imaginez la suite les antilles vont
s'engouffrer dans cette brève dans cette
brèche et dire que l'ensemble du
dispositif que nous avons les uns et les
autres adoptée au fur à mesure des lois
et est inadaptée conclure nous allons
raconter des histoires nous mais je ne
crois pas raisonnable même si chers
collègues
l'amendement 56 n'est pas défendu alors
je demande sur ces amendements l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la présidente je voudrais
mettre à part l'amendement numéro 19
rectifié vous apporter la réponse de la
commission sur cet amendement
immédiatement c'est un amendement qui
vise à ce que la durée de validité de
du test pour pouvoir embarquer
dans un pays qui serait affectée par
variant du coc vide extrêmement
dangereux qui serait soudainement
apparu
ne puisse pas être de moins de 72 heures
madame mais avant nous a expliqué tout à
l'heure que effectivement quand on a
exigé des tests il est arrivé que le
gouvernement exige un test de 24 heures
mais c'est bon droit et pour de bonnes
raisons que le gouvernement l'avait fait
le ministre lui dira mieux que moi mais
c'est tout simple si
la nature même de ce variant fait qu'un
test de plus de 24 heures n'a pas de
valeur parce que
[Musique]
la contamination peut fort bien se faire
dans ce cas
il faut laisser la liberté aux
gouvernements en fonction du variant il
faut toujours pouvoir s'adapter à la
réalité et donc notre avis est
défavorable pour des raisons qui ne sont
pas de principes qui sont de pratique
alors maintenant nous avons un certain
nombre d'amendements qui visent tous à
dire que face à une situation tout à
fait exceptionnelle
est fort improbable
de
d'émergence dans un pays donné
d'invariants extrêmement dangereux qui
exigerait comprennent des mesures
protectrices pour les français à
l'intérieur de nos frontières on puisse
demander avant l'embarquement non pas
simplement un test négatif
mais une vaccination à jour ou un
certificat de rétablissement là aussi
les choses ont changé depuis un an
restée crispée sur des positions qui
étaient juste ya un an qui serait
devenue mauvaise serait de la mauvaise
législation aujourd'hui quels sont les
changements ils sont multiples le virus
est plus viral le virus est moins
dangereux
et surtout le vaccin
ne protège actuellement
fait part hier à la contamination
actuellement que dans un tiers des cas
il reste une protection nécessaire et je
crois qu'il faut le rappeler pour chaque
individu surtout s'il est vulnérable
mais il ne fait pas barrage
dans plus d'un tiers des cas à la
contamination vous le savez tous par
conséquent dire que si il y à un nouveau
variant du coc vide qui surgit quelque
part si ce variant est très dangereux et
si pour protéger la france on demande
simplement un vaccin un jour alors que
déjà avec les variants actuelle dans des
deux tiers des cas le vaccin ne fait pas
barrage à la contamination est donc à la
contagiosité de la personne atteinte et
bien c'est très simple on rate notre
cible on ne protège plus alors bien sûr
du tout le monde le sait bien c'est
médical c'est pas un problème politique
il n'ya pas de sécurité absolue
évidemment le test peut rater sa cible
dans certains cas évidemment si le test
est trop ancien le virus peut faire son
oeuvre sur l'organisme du sujet qui
s'est fait tester mais bien sûr c'est
vrai mais au fond face au choix qu'on va
avoir pour protéger dans une situation
exceptionnelle est fort improbable le
territoire national le choix qu'on va
avoir
c'est un choix pratique vous voulez être
efficace vous demandez le test le test
est inconfortable
c'est plus facile parce que la plupart
des gens sont vaccinés c'est plus facile
de demander le vaccin eh bien je ne vous
propose pas la solution de facilité
sachant que maintenant il n'y a plus de
passes vaccinale parce sanitaires il n'y
a plus aucune mesure de contrainte que
ça ne changera pas la vie des gens c'est
pour au fond avoir un filet de sécurité
keane est appelé à jouer que de manière
tout à fait exceptionnelle mais tant
qu'à faire que de mettre ce filet de
sécurité autant qu'ils soient efficaces
plus chers collègues et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous invite vraiment
en toute sincérité et en toute humilité
devant les lacunes des connaissances que
nous pouvons avoir dans ce domaine
particulièrement quand comme c'est mon
cas
on n'est pas scientifique on n'est pas
médecin on n'est pas biologiste et au
fond nous n'avons pas l'être pour être
bon législateur nous devons simplement
utiliser correctement les informations
qui sont à notre disposition
sans fantasmer sur les messages
qu'impliquerait éventuellement les
dispositions comprend ce que nous devons
faire c'est voter pour des dispositions
utiles et n'ont pas voté pour conjurer
de mauvaise interprétation de la loi
soignante très concrets précis
pragmatique et efficace c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous propose en ce qui
me concerne de rejeter ces amendements
identiques pour des raisons de fou qui
me paraissent très importante et qui
sont de traiter correctement une
situation particulière dont j'espère
comme vous qu'elle n'arrivera jamais
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
aux amendements tendant à réintroduire
le justificatif de statut vaccinal et le
certificat de rétablissement parmi les
éléments du pass variant et du pass
outre-mer
comme vous l'indiquez la vaccination ou
une infection à la colite 19 réduit
pendant un temps significativement le
risque de survenue de formes graves
mais également elles réduisent le risque
de transmission à autrui quand bien même
elle ne l'empêchent pas totalement
ainsi exigé la présentation d'un
certificat de rétablissement ou un
justificatif de statut vaccinal
continue à faire sans ce
sens médicalement essence dans un
message de clarté de santé publique
les personnes disposant de ces documents
présentent moins de risque
d'hospitalisation et de surcharge du
système de santé monsieur le comte vous
proposez toutefois que ces documents ne
puisse être exigé que de manière
alternative et non cumulatives
à l'égard des voyageurs en provenance
des pays classés en zone rouge c'est à
dire ces pays où il ya une très forte
circulation active de lakovic 19 ou un
nouveau variant dangereux il est
nécessaire d'être en mesure de demander
un vaccin ou un certificat de
rétablissement et un test pas seulement
l'un ou l'autre
médicalement je ne peux pas dire autre
chose
le régime actuel en vigueur de
combinaisons des preuves est applicable
depuis plus d'un an sans difficulté il
n'est pas nécessaire ni souhaitable de
réduire le champ des possibles sur ce
point alors que l'épidémie nous a déjà
réservé de mauvaises surprises dans le
passé et nous impose l'humilité
cette combinaison sera décidée au cas
par cas en fonction du risque
c'est pour cela que je m'engage devant
vous à ce que si votre haute assemblée
retenez le principe d'une consultation
obligatoire sur la mise en oeuvre du
pass frontières
l'organisme scientifique appelée à se
prononcer s'exprime aussi sur la
combinaison en cause afin de garantir
publiquement que celle qui sera retenu
par décret laura était en fonction
d'éléments objectifs
transparents et médicaux
j'entends vos arguments monsieur le
rapporteur mais en tant que médecin je
ne peux qu'être favorable aux
amendements qui maintiennent le droit en
vigueur et vous invite monsieur le comte
a retiré le vôtre à leur profit
madame muller brawn votre amendement
quant à lui prévoit que l'examen de
dépistage
virologique doit avoir été réalisée au
maximum 72 heures auparavant comme vous
le savez la durée de validité des tests
dépend des connaissances scientifiques
en particulier en cas d'apparition de
nouveaux variants et de la situation
sanitaire général elle tient compte
aussi des pratiques de nos voisins afin
d'assurer la plus grande cohérence
possible dans des espaces de libre
circulation comme l'union européenne
c'est la raison pour laquelle ces durées
déterminées par voie réglementaire après
avis de la haute autorité de santé cette
manière de procéder garantie l'éclairage
scientifique en temps réel et une
capacité d'ajustement permanente par
décret n'apparaît pas souhaitable de
rectifier les choses aujourd'hui au
niveau de la loi par ailleurs le
règlement européen
2021 953 du parlement européen et du
conseil du 14 juin 2021 ne précise pas
que la durée de validité des examens de
dépistage virologique doit être fixée à
72 heures il se borne à définir le cadre
juridique du certificat qu'ovide
numérique de l'union européenne qui
d'autre est acceptée par l'ensemble des
états membres sans préciser les durées
de validité du résultat d'examens de
dépistage virologique la certificat de
rétablissement et d'un justificatif de
statut vaccinal pour ces raisons avis
défavorable
donc monsieur jomy
explications de vote
merci madame la présidente
le rapporteur nous a invités à ne pas
avoir un raisonnement figé moi je
partage totalement cette façon de penser
et bien si on ne veut pas avoir un
raisonnement figé en toute humilité
toute sincérité on doit dire que
personne d'entre nous n'est capable de
dire si le prochain variantes sur
viendra peut-être le 2,75
le meilleur outil ce sera d'avoir un
certificat de vaccination ou de faire un
test pcr pour se garantir que la
personne ne va pas amener le variant or
par votre position monsieur le
rapporteur vous nous priver
automatiquement de ces outils vous n'en
conserver qu'un seul parce que vous
présupposé que parce que actuellement
c'est le meilleur outil ce sera le
meilleur outil dans deux ou trois mois
mais nous nous réunirons pas à nouveau
dans deux ou trois mois et donc il est
plus sage de laisser ouvert la
possibilité de ces différents outils
ceci dit nous avons entendu ce qu'a
exprimé le ministre et donc la nécessité
de ne pas non plus fermé dans un choix
binaire donc nous allons adapter notre
position pour que le meilleur texte soit
adopté dans quelques instants à cet
égard et je voudrais dire aussi ne sera
porteur que en figeant en fermant comme
ça la situation autour de la seule
pratique du test pcr vous sortez le
vaccin
symboliquement du statut d' outils nous
permettant de nous protéger or si c'est
un outil un parfait sur la transmission
bien sûr il ne réduit que partiellement
le risque de transmission c'est tout de
même un outil qui a une certaine
efficacité
et là vous envoyer un message peut-être
à votre corps défendant mais à ceux qui
luttent contre le vaccin comme vous
envoyez à vous enverrez un peu plus tard
dans la discussion un autre message et
nous ne partageons pas ses messages il
ce ne sont ni justes sur un plan
scientifique ni adapté sur un plan
politique merci monsieur le comte
qui n'est pas sa place
merci madame la présidente désolé
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
compte tenu de la demande de monsieur le
ministre et
partir de mots je comprends que monsieur
bonnecarrère maintiendra son amendement
nous retirons notre amendement au profit
de celui de monsieur bonne carrière
et nous appelons tous ceux qui sont
attachés à la sécurité sanitaire des
français a envoyé de la part du sénat un
message sur la question de l'efficacité
des vaccins a voté un amendement qui
effectivement assure la sécurité
sanitaire des français dans un contexte
qui est toujours
pas certain nous sommes très étonnés que
en six mois monsieur le rapporteur soit
passé de d'une personne qui nous fait
voter le passé vaccinal à une personne
qui ne veut même plus mettre le vaccin
comme un élément de contrôle ce
finalement message vis-à-vis de
l'efficacité du vaccin ne nous semble
pas très opportun il est important de
maintenir l'ensemble des dispositifs et
j'entends monsieur le ministre
deux choses si nous tenions initialement
à ce que ce soit l'un ou l'autre ou le
troisième jeu vous indiquer la raison
dans un certain nombre de pays les
textes pcr coûte très cher jusqu'à 150
euros par personne pour une famille avec
deux enfants
ça peut être un blocage à un retour en
france c'est-à-dire à l'incapacité
d'arriver dans un pays où vous avez une
capacité de soins la deuxième chose
c'est lorsque vous êtes français et que
vous viviez à l'étranger et que vous
n'avez pas le bon schéma vaccinal
si on exige une combinaison des deux
alors il y a un problème
donc nous retirons cet amendement au
profit de celui de sue bonnecarrère mais
nous vous demandons à trouver des
dispositifs qui n'exclut aucun français
qui vit à l'étranger de la capacité de
revenir en france lorsqu'il se trouve en
danger dans une zone qui est
menacé par un variant particulièrement
grave
merci monsieur benarroch
oui madame la présidente sauf erreur de
ma part les amendements 6 36 54 sur
lui-même il donc seront votées en
sortent donc en fait c'est l'amendement
non pas seulement de monsieur votre
carrière mais c'est celui aussi de notre
groupe est aussi celui des indépendants
et je rajouterais d'ailleurs que les
deux amendements qui ont été retirées au
moins de la séance celui qui était
présenté par monsieur alain richard et
moi m toualy pour un air des pays est
celui qui devait être défendu il me
semble par air de paris re pour rds eux
étaient également les mêmes donc je
pense réellement c'est aussi l'avis du
ministre donc je pense réellement
monsieur le rapporteur que c'est
essentiel pour faire en sorte que cet
article 2 soit voté par l'ensemble des
bords de cette assemblée ce qui serait
quand même une bonne chose que vous
puissiez accepté de donner un avis
favorable cet ensemble d'amendements qui
viennent de pratiquement tous les
groupes qui sont représentés ici
merci je présidente
nfc la présidente pensent que
l'intervention et la déclaration du
ministre brawn nous éclaire ce soir sur
le sens qu'il est être porté par la
haute assemblée sur une discussion
importante
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
puisque par votre intervention vous nous
amenez en ce qui nous concerne a retiré
l'amendement numéro 40 sur lequel nous
étions prêts à
envisager un scrutin public et nous nous
rabattons mais au meilleur sens du terme
sont les amendements présentés par les
autres groupes parce que effectivement
vous nous avez rappelé phil
le bon chemin et suivants je n'ai pas
être très agréable sur le rapporteur et
vous voudrez mais mon excusé par avance
il y a beaucoup d' incendies de forêt en
ce pays et ce soir vous avez manif
manipuler ou manifester une forme de
d'enfumage généralisée vis-à-vis de
plusieurs groupes de notre assemblée je
le dis ici très simplement
la raison qui est la vôtre
que vous avez présenté de manière la
plus scientifique possible n'est pas que
scientifique elle est aussi lié à une
situation politique qui vous lie à un
autre groupe à l'assemblée nationale
certes
mais je le confirme et je ne souhaite
pas je ne souhaite pas que les débats
politiques qui sont ceux de la haute
assemblée ce palier finalement à des
contraintes et des considérations qui
sont celles et ceux de
la majorité aient l'air ici présente je
le dis très simplement
parce que sur un sujet aussi important
sur lequel nous sommes tous battus à
savoir favoriser encourager et presque
pour ce qui nous concerne obligé à la
vaccination nous soyons obligés de faire
un retour en arrière ce qui est tout à
fait inacceptable au regard des enjeux
de santé publique dans notre pays donc
je le dis très simplement nous voterons
par un scrutin public favorablement aux
amendements portés par nos collègues
notamment monsieur bonnecarrère parce
que nous estimons que c'est le bien de
la nation qui est en cause monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur leicester tu l
merci madame la présidente monsieur mise
chers collègues si nous sommes nombreux
à intervenir c'est parce que nous voyons
bien qu'il y a là un événement d'une
certaine gravité en cet instant au céda
parce que il ya 48 heures monsieur le
rapporteur vous étiez tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'il y eut les trois
modalités
le vaccin le test et le certificat de
rétablissement
et puis votre pensée a évolué
et il est difficile
de ne pas penser en effet que la
situation complexe qui est celle de
l'assemblée nationale peut conduire
certains et après tout
il y aurait une logique à imaginer qu'il
faudrait que nos débats ici soit guidé
par le fait de favoriser tel ou tel vote
de tel ou tel groupe à l'assemblée
nationale mais moi je dis que c'est
grave parce que la question est de
savoir ce qu'on pense ce qui nous paraît
juste et vrai et je crois que le
bicamérisme suppose que chaque assemblée
se détermine par rapport à elle même et
puis après on verra il existe une
commission mixte paritaire
et donc il est très important me
semble-t-il alors que nous sommes très
nombreux
je pense au combat de nos amis
d'outre-mer très difficile pour défendre
le vaccin face à des oppositions
irrationnel
nous avons défendu le vaccin
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne revenions pas en
arrière pour des questions d'opportunité
je crois que ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée se passe à l'assemblée mais
ne doit pas déteindre sur
ce que nous allons faire au sénat en
toute indépendance c'est comme ça que
doit fonctionner la république
6 monsieur le président richard
adam la présidente
j'ai demandé à mon groupe de retirer
l'amendement que nous présentions et qui
était dans le sens de la
convergence d'autres amendements elle
celui du gouvernement
je les fais pour une raison principale
qui est le raisonnement praticiens
défendu par philippe bas
nous devrons de toute façon le
gouvernement en fonction lorsque une
nouvelle situation de circulation
inquiétantes se développera devra
utiliser les moyens les plus applicable
et plus pratique pour traiter cette
nouvelle situation de circulation virale
le vaccin
sera moins adaptés à cette situation et
d'en faire donc une preuve en quelque
sorte concurrente du test viral et
virologiques ne nous semble pas ne me
semble pas au moment où on parle comme
une solution adaptée j'ai entendu
l'argument ministre et j'ai été frappée
que parlant au banc du gouvernement ils
disent en tant que médecin je ne peux
pas prendre une autre position
j'entends tout à fait il respecte cette
approche mais en l'occurrence il s'agit
de faire marcher un système de contrôle
public dans une situation de crise et il
me semble que il vaut mieux se tenir à
l'utilisation du test qui décrit la
situation qui permet d'identifier la
situation de circulation la plus récente
la plus réelle alors que l'utilisation
du vaccin ou d'ailleurs du certificat de
rétablissement qui date de trois mois ou
six mois
serait un signe trompeur
il me semble donc que c'est un motif
déterminant en tout cas c'est celui qui
m'a déterminé à choisir de ne pas suivre
cette logique là et après on peut se
compose à dresser des procès politiques
faut conclure la plage ou moins
d'élégance mais il se trouve conquiert
en l'occurrence la simple réalité
conduit à cette solution
merci monsieur opère
comme la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le président richard
ait parlé avec beaucoup de sagesse on
parle des tests on parle des vaccins je
suis très heureux que le rapporteur bas
10 implicitement que le meilleur parce
sanitaires c'est par le contrôle des
tests
revenons au vaccin moi ce que j'ai
appris en tant que praticien c'est qu'un
vaccin efficace il est fait avec la
souche la plus récente et on a prouvé
que le vaccin que le
virus au micron le variant au micron ne
réagissait pas aux vaccins et j'ai peur
que dans l'avenir les variants futur ne
réagissent pas donc j'entends bien
monsieur bonnecarrère sur le vin sur le
vaccin mais
prenons un peu de recul prenant un peu
de recul ne nous obstinons pas sur
quelque chose qui a marché au départ et
qui marche mois et qui marche mais de
moins en moins merci
merci madame v rien
merci madame la présidente alors quel
est l'objectif de se protéger très
clairement outre le fait de ne pas
contaminer c'est surtout de ne pas
engorger nos hôpitaux on le sait alors
qu'est ce qui permet le mieux de ne pas
engorger nos hôpitaux et ça aussi on le
sait c'est le vaccin parce
qu'effectivement ça n'empêche pas
d'attraper la maladie ça empêche juste
d'aller au réanimation d'aller aux
urgences et d'aller engorgé nos hôpitaux
c'est bien ça l'objectif du vaccin
maintenant je veux mais dans le cas
d'une famille qui va voyager il va aller
passer ses vacances à l'étranger dans un
pays quel qu'il soit peut-être même la
suisse un pays frontalier qui tout d'un
coup il devient rouge on ne sait pas
pourquoi voilà il ya et donc pour
pouvoir revenir alors peut-être que la
suisse est pas le meilleur exemple parce
que je pense qu'on trouve assez
facilement ou aller faire un test pcr
mais malgré tout pour les frontaliers
qui vont devoir faire un test pcr à
chaque fois qu'ils vont devoir aller
travailler tous les 48 heures vous vous
souvenez de cela tout ce qui n'est pas à
faire maintenant qu'on est vacciné et
que l'on peut voyager grâce à ce vaccin
eh bien il va falloir le faire et alors
si on est dans un pays plus éloignés on
est en vacances avec sa famille et on
doit trouver comment avant son départ en
avion allait faire son test pcr le pays
et éventuellement très cher et imaginer
un des membres de la famille française
qui est en vacances quelque part qui
doit revenir et un des membres l'un des
enfants est positif vous faites quoi
vous le laissez vous resté toute la
famille vous annulez tous vos billets
d'avion vous rester 15 jours il vous
rentrez pas chez vous c'est bien ce qui
se passe et donc si l'objectif c'est
d'éviter d'emmerder les français puisque
ça a été récitée peut-être que de fait
de garder trois possibilités c'est à
dire la guérison le vaccin ou le test
pcr qui n'oblige donc aucunement à la
vaccination et permet aussi de s'en
sortir probablement ça laisse beaucoup
plus de souplesse pour voyager pour les
français comme pour les étrangers
d'ailleurs
merci mendy folco
oui merci en réalité tout à l'heure je
voulais réagir aux propos de monsieur
juillet qui s'inquiétait de savoir que
si au bout de deux mois trois mois telle
ou telle mesure était la plus efficace
je rappelle simplement que le deuxième
alinéa de l'article prévoit que si tu de
ce positif et mis en oeuvre par le
gouvernement s'il doit être prolongé au
bout d'un mois il doit repasser par le
parlement donc en réalité votre
inquiétude c'est un tout seul puisque si
ou d'un mois on ne sait pas si c'est le
meilleur dispositif qui fonctionne on
pourra re voter
merci monsieur hervé
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
insister sur le fait que au 31 juillet
au soir et ça n'est pas le sujet de ce
soir mais il va se passer quelque chose
c'est que le pass vaccinale elle passe
sanitaires vont mourir de leur belle
mort donc mes chers collègues si on
parle de l'incitation la vaccination au
travers de mesures comme le pass axial
ou parce sanitaire cet argument ne tient
pas puisque ces dispositifs n'existeront
plus là on parle d'un dispositif très
particulier qui consiste pour
l'essentiel
à imposer pour le trafic aérien
la réalisation d'un test pcr pour
l'intégralité des passagers
je peux je poserai on pense dans les
exemples qu'on peut citer quand même
beau souvent je l' ai moi même vécu ma
chère collègue g pourrait vous donner
l'exemple mais quand par exemple
l'ensemble de territoire d'outre-mer ont
le test pcr était obligatoire vous êtes
positif vacciner ou pas vous n'embarquer
pas moi le 31 décembre j'ai fait un test
à la réunion j'ai été vacciné trois fois
j'étais positif je je je n'ai pas
embarquer et je me suis mis en
quarantaine donc si on veut avoir une
garantie certaine certaines
indépendamment du statut vaccinal je
répète j'étais vacciner trois fois sur
une garantie certaine que aucun
passagers n'embarquent en ayant le lac
au vide on teste tout l'avion on teste
tout l'avion on s'efforce tout l'avion
un test pcr et on exclue forcément les
autres dispositifs le certificat de
rétablissement ou le certificat de
vaccination qui ne sont pas en mesure
d'apporter la preuve que la personne
n'est pas porteuse du virus c'est la
raison pour laquelle mes chers collègues
je ne voterai aucun de ces amendements
et je suis très attaché à la rédaction
proposée par philippe bas en tant que
vacciner et aux nouveaux titres aussi la
défense des libertés publiques
mais si monsieur joyan des
oui merci à mme la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
j'ai vraiment le sentiment qu'on est
dans un moment de notre travail de
législateur
ici au sénat je frappe à l'assemblée
nationale mais ici au sénat justement on
est en train de légiférer en tirant des
plans sur la comète est dans un moment
je reviens sur les propos de notre
rapporteur qui se place dans le cas
d'une nouvelle épidémie très forte
subite etc et nous ne savons
rien de ce qui va se passer à ce moment
là et moi je veux prendre date pour vous
dire que quoi quel que soit le texte
qu'on va voter ce soir il sera
inapplicable et si le 6 et si toutefois
la circonstance venait à surgir telle
qu'elle est envisagée par notre ami
philippe may je pense que la meilleure
solution c'est de revenir devant le
parlement de regarder la situation de
quoi il s'agit nouveaux variants pas
nouveau variant les tests marche ils
marchent pas aujourd'hui tout est dans
la nature moi je vais aggravé notre cas
dans les crocs star parce que on dit on
teste l'avion tout l'avion on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
qui ont qu'ovide symptomatique j'ai
beaucoup de témoignages vécus qui sont
négatifs pendant quatre jours et qu'ils
sont positifs au bout du cinquième jour
alors que ça fait six jours qu'ils sont
contaminants donc mes chers collègues
nous ne savons rien de ce qui va se
passer mais là on est chacun donne à
chacun donne sa sa certitude moi ce que
je suggère pour être sûr d'avoir juste
ses joueurs d'avoir juste co2 rejeté cet
article là et puis de revenir devant le
parlement quand on aura des vrais
éléments factuels on nous dira où sont
les virus quelles sont leurs intensités
de quoi on a besoin tout ce qui est
proposé sur tous les bancs ne concerne
so lu ment pas absolument pas la
situation future on essaie depuis une
situation actuelle de déduire ce qu'on
va faire dans un moment on sait pas ce
qu'on aura affaire c'est quand même un
peu ubuesque et ça c'est pas l'assemblée
nationale j'ai été élu benjamin de cette
maison en 95 j'ai vécu des bons moments
mais le moment qu'on est en train de
vivre ce soir merci ça franchement je
n'ai pas vécu beaucoup et donc je veux
vraiment prendre date le rapport de mai
c'est là par ailleurs les mêmes gens qui
m'ont appris beaucoup la parole je veux
simplement dire que c'est moi qui décide
monsieur sylla de 40 ans même si vous
avez la parole je comprends que l'europe
on cherche un jeu quelque chose de
concret mais je sens quelque chose de
juste voilà deux qu'on sache ce qu'on va
faire mais la mauvaise main monsieur
joyandet c'est moi qui décide ici c'est
moi qui préside donc quand je dis qu'on
arrête c'est terminé vous êtes trop
nombreux à prendre la parole ne peut pas
laisser merci même jasmin merci merci
beaucoup matin de la part même la
présidente je crois que nous sommes à un
moment important dans les différents
échanges et je crois que c'est bien
c'est très bien que nous puissions
échanger de cette manière là parce qu'en
fait nous nous rendons compte que la
situation est devenue complexe mais une
chose est sûre le vaccin a ses limites
la cinétique vaccinale j'en ai parlé il
ya quelques temps ici même la cinétique
vaccinale est bien l ea compte errements
d'une part d'autre part le vaccin n'est
pas efficace où tous les mutants sud il
n'est pas efficace il était peut-être
efficace tout certain certains mais avec
tous les variants qu'on a toutes les
mutations qu on en aura jamais un vaccin
efficace et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je suis très favorable au
fait qu'il y ait des tests le test
permet le test qui sont à pc ou
peut-être antigénique permettra d'avoir
un moment donné la situation de la
personne et ce que nous avons pas fait
et que le gouvernement a refusé il ya
quelques mois c'est la sérologie on
aurait pu voir justement le statut
sérologique des gens le taux d'anticorps
qu'ils ont on dit que ce n'est pas
efficace mais ce serait un rêve un
indicateur ce serait sans doute un
indicateur important donc je crois au
moment où nous nous sommes là maintenant
c'est intéressant mais nous avons tous
et tous pratiquement je dirais étaient
vaccinés une fois deux fois trois fois
palmable - peut-être quatre ou cinq fois
tout simplement parce que nous n'avons
pas de réaction liée au type de virus en
fonction de la période donc il est vrai
que nous aurons probablement un virus
beaucoup plus est plus important qu'il y
aura peut-être de faire des formes très
grave mais aujourd'hui je crois que
faire le test faire des tests il faut
les privilégiés alors pour les personnes
déjà vaccinées je ne dis pas que parce
que des personnes ne seraient pas
vaccinés aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait à
être offensés non je crois que nous
sommes tous et toutes conscient que
beaucoup d'entre nous ont été vaccinées
une fois deux fois trois fois et que
régulièrement nous voyons dans nos bancs
des personnes qui ne sont pas là parce
qu'ils ont le virus parce qu'ils ont pas
forcément le même virus avant tout
simplement pour vous dire que nous
devons faire preuve d'humilité mais
d'axer notre action sur la prévention
merci merci madame guillotin
merci madame la présidente je vais faire
une explication de vote assez courtes
déjà priori moi je serais favorable à la
proposition de dire qu'on peut avoir le
test le vaccin ou le certificat de de
guérison ça reste quand même quelque
chose qui est scientifiquement et
médicalement reconnu donc on va pas
réinventer ici les études et refaire
refaire de la médecine dans cet
hémicycle moi ce que je crois est ce que
je ressens c'est qu'on est sur une perte
de compromis aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle faut se le dire qu'on essaye
de chercher la voie de passage la plus
adaptée pour que le texte soit
équilibrée puisse arriver à son terme
donc moi je pense que si cette solution
là est la bonne il faut y aller c'est
pas la peine de cumuler le peut-être le
pass vaxy enfin le on est plus serein
parce sanitaire parce que quelqu'un dit
qu'il allait tomber effectivement mais
dans le pass sanitaire il ya à la fois
le vaccin à la fois le test est à la
fois le certificat de guérison par
contre là n'exclut pas l'autre et je ne
vois pas en quoi mettre le vaccin sauf
si c'est un irritant qui devient une
limite rouge vous êtes en mer et le
vaccin n'enlève rien à ce qu'ils veulent
pas le faire et du coup peuvent quand
même faire leur test je ne vois pas ce
que l'un empêche de l'autre donc je
serais favorable à ces amendements
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 19 de madame hilaire
brawn qui a reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est donc pas adoptée
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ''le par les
groupes les républicains et socialistes
sont les amendements identiques 6 36 et
54 et je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable et l'avis du
gouvernement est favorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
sun ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 119
sur les amendements identiques numéro 6
36 rectifié 54 compte tenu de l'ensemble
des délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 344 un nombre de suffrages
exprimés 338 pour l'adoption 151 contre
187 le sénat n'a pas adopté
alors deux amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le numéro 31 de
madame vogel
merci madame la présidente
donc dans une ordonnance du 18 août 2001
le conseil d'état avait rappelé que le
droit pourra ressortissants français
établis à l'étranger d'entrée sur le
territoire national et est une liberté
fondamentale
partant de là cet amendement à vocation
essayé de respecter cette ordonnance du
conseil d'état est de concilier la
nécessaire protection sanitaire avec la
protection de la liberté fondamentale
des français établis hors de france
il y a donc deux dispositions lune qui
est simplement d'inscrire clairement
dans la loi que les exigences ne saurait
interdire le retour sur le territoire
national d'un ou d'une ressortissante
française et la deuxième chose c'est
d'inscrire la possibilité que les tests
soient effectués à l'arrivée pour les
français qui sont à l'étranger je
voudrais préciser tout de suite que non
ça n'implique pas sauf si évidemment
quand le gouvernement applique cette loi
il fait n'importe quoi ce que je ne
saurais croire que des français prennent
l'avion ou le train en étant positif et
en contaminant tout le monde parce qu'il
ferait leur test à l'arrivée ça
n'implique pas forcément ça cette
disposition c'est juste pour offrir une
base légale au gouvernement qui
permettent d'autoriser les tests à
l'arrivée pour les cas où ce soit
indispensable au respect de l'ordonnancé
du conseil d'état est possible dans le
respect des exigences sanitaires
appropriées je vous rappelle par
ailleurs que les personnes qui sont dans
cette situation sont souvent
vacciner mais peuvent être dans des
situations le schéma vaccinal du pays
dans lequel ils vivent ne permet pas de
respecter le schéma vaccinal français
parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès aux mêmes
vaccins et c'est une possibilité bien
sûr pour éviter qu'ils soient
discriminées serait de rendre les tests
pour rembourser au gratuit si le
gouvernement fait ça il aura pas besoin
d'appliquer cette possibilité mais voilà
c'est simplement un une possibilité une
base légale pour éviter les
discriminations
merci je vais vous demander juste parler
un tout petit peu moins fort pour qu'on
puisse laisser
nos collègues défendre leurs amendements
s'il vous plaît
merci alors le numéro 64 modem varaillas
ce we allant dans le même sens cet
amendement vise à ménager les modalités
d'usagé certificat sanitaire de voyage
afin de ne pas pénaliser les
ressortissants français et étrangers qui
souhaitent se rendre sur le territoire
sur notre territoire national
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
j'oserais dire à madame la sénatrice vos
gueules que
la commission des lois a émis un avis
défavorable malheureusement sur son
amendement parce que une fois que les
personnes sont arrivées sur le
territoire national si
dans une situation où il s'agit d'un
virus d'un variant du virus très
dangereux
s'il leur test fait uniquement à
l'arrivée sur le territoire national est
négatif il faut encore décidé de ce
qu'on va faire de ces personnes et ça va
être la quarantaine je suis pas sûr que
ce soit mieux pour elle d'avoir une
quarantaine à l'arrivée sur le
territoire national que de retarder un
petit peu son voyage donc pour ces
raisons à ces pratiques est tout en
voyant bien votre intention positive à
l'égard des voyageurs nous pensons que
ce n'est pas leur intérêt en réalité
d'adopter ce genre de dispositif la vie
et donc défavorable et il est aussi
défavorable sur l'amendement numéro
64 parce que en réalité
il s'agit pas d'interdire le retour de
qui que ce soit sur le territoire
national mais sa tente juste un peu que
les conditions soient redevenues
favorables pour que
la protection de nos concitoyens sur le
territoire national soit assurée donc si
vous acceptiez de retirer votre
amendement je crois que ce serait
préférable sinon l'avis de la commission
a été défavorable merci la vie du
gouvernement et ses ministres
dames la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
les amendements tendant à prévoir à des
dispositifs spécifiques pour les
français de l'étranger afin qu'ils ne
puissent se voir refuser le retour en
france
l'invs au gel ou proposés ainsi qu'un
test de dépistage leur soit proposée à
leur arrivée sur le territoire pourtant
permettre aux français de l'étranger de
réaliser un test à leur arrivée sur le
territoire national viderait de passes
variant de sa substance en effet comme
cela a été rappelé deux visent à freiner
l'arrivée sur le territoire national de
ce nouveau variant or cet amendement
permettrait aux français de l'étranger
alors qu'ils viennent d'un pays où un
nouveau variant circulent et sont
éventuellement porter de celui ci d'être
en contact avec d'autres voyageurs
durant leur trajet en avion ou en train
et serait alors présents sur le
territoire le risque de contamination
est avérée sauf comme cela a été dit à m
tout le monde en quarantaine même la
sénatrice permettez-moi d'observer que
le pass outre-mer est applicable qu'aux
trajet entre l'hexagone et les
collectivités ultramarines et ne peut
avoir pour effet d'interdire un retour
sur territoire national d'un
ressortissant français
de manière générale le droit fondamental
de tout français de rejoindre le
territoire national se concilie avec
l'objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
de protection de la santé publique
la jurisprudence admet que des
restrictions peuvent être apportés si le
bénéfice pour la protection de la santé
publique excède l'atteinte portée à ce
droit fondamental
l'émergence éventuelle d'un nouveau
variant avec des caractéristiques
inconnu à l'étranger
justifie de protéger le territoire
national en instaurant un pass variant
qui s'appliquerait temporairement aux
français résidant à l'étranger en
revanche comme vous le savez il a été
jugé qu'il ne peut être imposée de
motifs impérieux aux nationaux pour
revenir sur le territoire et le projet
de loi ne reviens pas sur ce point pour
ces raisons avis défavorable
mais si monsieur chanterelle pour
explication de vote
merci merci madame la présidente je
pense que c'est un point essentiel qui a
peut-être pu échapper qui a pu vous
échapper mais ce n'est pas anodin du
tout ces deux amendements parce qu'il ya
eu un précédent assez grave de part je
dirais votre gouvernement c'était dans
c'était en janvier 2021 mais bon c'est
le même gouvernement il ya eu quelques
petits changements mais c'est dans la
continuité
il ya eu un précédent très grave à la
fin du mois de janvier 2021 où il ya un
décret qui a été pris qui a exigé des
motifs impérieux pour nos propres
ressortissants qui n'étaient pas en
france c'est à dire que ce jour là le
gouvernement a décidé de faire le tri
auprès de ses propres ressortissants
à l'opposition même des conventions qui
ont été rappelés justement européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme les
principes qui énumère clairement le
principe du droit fondamental d'un
ressortissant de pouvoir entrer et
sortir de son pays et quand je vous dis
que ça c'est un précédent grave ça a été
d'ailleurs on a mené la fronde au
conseil d'état qui a cassé ce de créer
pourquoi c'est un précédent grave parce
qu'il ya des personnes encore moins bien
intentionnés que vous qui sont
d'ailleurs pas forcément dans cette
assemblée mais dans l'autre qui feront
également le tri entre nos
ressortissants sur d'autres critères et
c'est en ça que
en tant que législateur nous devons
sécuriser pour que ce genre de chose
n'ait plus lieu et en votant pour cet
amendement c'est ce que nous ferons
mais si le compte
même si madame la présidente monsieur
ministre si les français sont dans un
territoire où ils sont en danger
justement parce qu'à ce variant et que
vous ne permettez pas assez français de
rentrer parce qu'il n'y a pas la
possibilité de faire le test nous avons
connu ça il ya quelques années qu'est ce
que vous leur répondez rester là où vous
êtes ce n'est pas notre problème qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez c'est bien
pour ça que nous déposons cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur la situation que
vous évoquez bien entendu inacceptable
et comme je les ai déjà dit auprès de
l'assemblée je m'engage au cas par cas
par des mesures de gestion à régler ce
genre de problème pour récupérer nos
ressortissants qui seraient coincées
entre guillemets à l'étranger dans ce
cadre de situations
merci je vais mettre au voide
l'amendement 31 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient pas adopté l'amendement
164 même avis même vote
même avis même votre merci maman 41
monsieur chanterelle
oui alors cet amendement il vise
justement à réparer une injustice qui
frappe les nous honorons nos
compatriotes qui sont établis hors de
france qui n'ont pas forcément justement
la possibilité d'avoir accès à un vaccin
ou à des tests à des dépistages
et que justement en cas d'entrée en
vigueur du dispositif prévu au premier
alinéa de l'article 2 prive de leur
droit fondamental que je vous ai exposé
précédemment dont c'est cet amendement
il prévoit justement que le gouvernement
puisse établir après concertation avec
les conseillers des français de
l'étranger puisque en plus on a la
chance
d'avoir des élus à travers le monde qui
vivent dans les pays concernés dont qui
ont une expertise qui ont la possibilité
justement de dire les faits dans leur
pays s'il ya des accès ou non au vaccin
s'il ya des accès aux noms aux tests pcr
est de permettre justement à travers
cette cette concertation d'avoir une
liste des pays où le présent décret
finalement ne s'appliquerait pas afin de
permettre chose sur laquelle vous vous
êtes engagé justement monsieur le
ministre de permettre à nos
ressortissants d'accéder au territoire
national
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporta il est défavorable madame la
présidente mais si l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie merci je vais donc même
mettre aux voix la maman 41 qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement 51
monsieur chassaing
la présidente monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur donc si vous
voulez c'est simplement que le délai
d'un mois nous sommes trop court
entraîne une sollicitation du parlement
qui ne semble pas justifiée cet
amendement vise à supprimer ce délai
permettra au gouvernement de prendre des
mesures de prévention jusqu'au 31
juillet 23
mai si l'amant 53 même qui autant cessé
un amendement de repli qui prolonge au
delà de moi
merci l'avis de la commission ces deux
rapporteurs
le président cela mérite qu'on s'y
arrête un instant c'est vraiment la
marque de fabrique du sénat que de ne
pas vouloir donner des pouvoirs
exceptionnels au gouvernement sans
exercer son contrôle et 7 une règle que
nous avons toujours appliqués ont dit au
gouvernement s'il ya urgence vous pouvez
restreindre les libertés dans un but
d'intérêt général
mais pas plus d'un mois sans un vote du
parlement donc du coup ces deux
amendements qui vise à retirer
l'intervention du parlement et l'autre à
allonger le délai d'un mois deux mois ce
que nous n'avions pas fait jusqu'à
présent
fait l'objet d'un avis défavorable de
notre commission
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
comme la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs concernant la demande de mme
en 51 monsieur le sénateur votre
amendement vise à supprimer la clause de
revoyure parlementaire à un mois qui a
été adopté par la commission cette
clause de revoyure reprend un mécanisme
propre à la prorogation de deux régimes
d'exception la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence fondée sur la loi du 11 avril
1955 ou delà de 12 jours et de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire au delà d'un mois
nécessitant une autorisation du
parlement à défaut le droit commun est
rétabli le présent projet de loi acte la
fin des régimes d'exception d'état
d'urgence sanitaire de la gestion de la
sortie de crise sanitaire désormais le
droit commun re devient la norme
ce dispositif est uniquement transitoire
il est applicable que jusqu'au 31
janvier 2023 et tous les dispositifs
actuels de contrôle parlementaire
renforcer des décisions que l'exécutif
est amené à prendre en ce domaine sont
maintenus par le présent projet de loi
sans qu'il soit besoin de prévoir d'en
voter une nouvelle au bout d'un mois
cela étant le gouvernement entend la
volonté de votre commission de prévoir
cette clause de rendez vous j'aurai
l'occasion de préciser que le délai d'un
mois et en tout état de cause trop court
et je vais le faire mais sur le principe
même de cette nouvelle clause de
rendez-vous qui augura peut-être d'un
quatrième projet de loi d'urgence
sanitaire le gouvernement s'en remet à
la sagesse de votre haute assemblée
concernant l'amendement 53
l'amendement vise à allonger à deux mois
le délai de la clause de revoyure
parlementaire lorsqu'un nouveau variant
de la queue vide est détectée nous est
utile des études pardon scientifiques
prennent davantage qu'un mois pour
identifier ces mutations
la transmissibilité sa gravité son
échappement à l'immunité conférée par
les vaccins ou une infection invariants
préexistants fasse un nouveau variant
dont les caractéristiques ne sont par
définition pas encore connue afin de ne
pas exposer la population française à un
danger il est préférable
d'immédiatement réagir ainsi une
variante delta dont les études sont
ensuite démontré qu'il présente une
transmissibilité moindre gravité accrue
a été détecté en octobre 2020 selon l'
oms toutefois il n'a été classé comme
variant que préoccupant que le 11 mai
2021 on ne disposant que d'un seul mois
il est très peu probable que les études
scientifiques puissent établir
suffisamment la dangerosité ou non d'un
nouveau variant de lakovic 19 à défaut
d'éléments le dispositif ne pourra
certainement pas être prolongé ce délai
trop bref risque de nous amener à
initier un grand nombre de projets de
loi qui n'aboutiront pas ce qu'ils ne
serviraient pas l'objectif poursuivi
pour ses verrons pour ces raisons pardon
avis favorable à cet allongement du
délai de la clause de rendez vous
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement donc 51 rectifié qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission a
un avis de sagesse du gouvernement
monsieur chassaing voulait prendre la
parole
à vous retirer votre amendement très
bien merci
bien sûr nous avons bien compris donc je
mets au voit donc l'amendement 53 qui a
reçu donc un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est donc pas adopter
l'amendement 15 rectifié vise le
monsieur k dick
merci madame la présidente
la commission des lois suivant
l'excellent travail de son excellent
rapporteur
a réintroduit un amendement lr adopté à
l'assemblée nationale avant que
l'article 2 ne soit supprimé cette
disposition prévoit la consultation des
élus des collectivités d'outre-mer
exécutifs locaux et parlementaires en
cas de rétablissement du pass sanitaires
pour s'y rendre il
m'apparut cohérent que cette
consultation des élus soit étendu à ceux
des français établis hors de france
alors que nous discutons de la
possibilité de réinstaurer le pass
sanitaires aux frontières pour venir en
france en effet les élus des français
l'étranger dont une partie est
représentée à l'assemblée des français
de l'étranger peuvent apporter des
informations pertinentes sur l'état
sanitaire des pays dans lesquels ils
vivent comme alerter sur les capacités
de test ils peuvent utilement éclairer
la décision du gouvernement c'est le
sens de l'amendement que je vous propose
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
rapportable
je comprends très bien
l'amendement de nos collègues et ils ont
sûrement raison sur un point c'est que
les élus à l'assemblée des français de
l'étranger ont des choses à dire
mais
mettez-vous de l'autre côté de la
barrière c'est à dire du côté des
autorités sanitaires
invariants extrêmement dangereux
apparaît dans un pays croyez vous
réellement possible de réunir à paris
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
pour prendre des mesures urgentes et
bien non c'est impossible c'est
pratiquement impossible de faire ceci ça
induirait des délais de consultation qui
empêcherait à la mesure d'être prise
vous avez cité le cas de l'outre-mer
mais justement pour l'outre-mer ce sont
les présidents de collectivités qui
émettront un avis cet avis il peut être
donné dans les heures qui suivent la
constatation qui lie à
l'émergence d'un virus dangereux
l'asymétrie ne peut pas être fait elle
pourrait l'être que je vous ferai une
autre réponse mais en l'occurrence sa
soeur tu as des difficultés pratiques
réelles je vous remercie de
l'appréciation vous avez bien voulu
faire de notre travail mais c'est
justement en raison du caractère assez
j'espère approfondie du travail de la
commission des lois que nous avons été
obligés de vous faire cette réponse
en étant navré de devoir voulais faire
mais si vous voulez retirer votre
amendement serons très heureux bien sûr
même si l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
ministre mais ma vie dans la prison
merci monsieur k dick
vous le retirez monsieur k dick
alors écoutez moi je vous parlais juste
d'un parallélisme des formes d'accord
c'est qu'avant de prendre une décision
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
compris pour les territoires d'outre-mer
et vela pour les français l'étranger ce
serait pas possible de les consulter
avant alors vous dites qu'il faudrait du
temps pour réunir l'assemblée des
français à l'étranger je vais vous faire
un aveu une confidence il existe de nos
jours et c'est très utilisé la
visioconférence et à l'assemblée des
français de l'étranger ils ont pris
l'habitude justement de se réunir très
vite comme d'ailleurs les élus des
français l'étranger et c'est comme ça
que nous communiquons aujourd'hui entre
nous donc pour répondre à votre juste et
je trouve très pertinente remarque je
veux vous faire passer un message qu'il
y à un nouveau procédé aujourd'hui qui
peut répondre a justement la vocation
qui a été attribué au donc aux outre-mer
nous pouvons effectivement avoir cette
réponse c'est un principe républicain
d'égalité qui se trouve juste entre la
liberté la fraternité et c'est ce que je
réclame pour les français de l'étranger
sinon ça donnerait l'impression qu'il ya
une france à part
et ça c'est pas un principe républicain
merci merci alors donc je mets aux voix
à monsieur le comte excusez moi
merci madame la présidente du smi/sli
chers collègues sur le fond j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que notre hameau
l'amendement de notre collègue
chanterelle qui proposait tout à l'heure
une consultation des conseillers des
français de l'étranger était plus
adaptée toutefois monsieur le rapporteur
je me sens quand même très mal à l'aise
avec votre réponse
sommes-nous lorsque nous vivons à
l'étranger des français de catégorie b
qui nous n'avons pas les mêmes droits
qui ne sommes pas dignes d'être
consultés lorsque l'on prend des
décisions qui nous concernent
eh bien non en tout cas nous
revendiquons le fait d'être dans la
communauté nationale à égalité et à
partir de là effectivement il n'est pas
illégitime qu'on nous pose des questions
et on peut peut-être aussi apporter des
réponses et à partir du moment où la
pandémie et mondial s'est pas inutile de
regarder au delà des frontières
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente une consultation
visioconférence ne serait pas valable en
l'occurrence et il n'est pas précisé
d'ailleurs dans cet amendement que c'est
ainsi qu'elle devrait être fait merci
donc je mets au voile amendement 15 qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
ses contres qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 42 monsieur lurel
madame le président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues je demande de
remplacer le risque de saturation du
système de santé par l'apparition de
nouveaux variants constituant une menace
sanitaire grave pour deux raisons dans
le grand auteur de cet article
concernant l'hexagone on évoque
l'apparition d'un possible variant de
nouveaux variants
là c'est plus ça c'est la saturation du
système hospitalier or cette structure
elle l'offre dessous est chez nous et
partout dans les outre-mer est
structurellement insuffisante la raison
pour laquelle je me suis opposé à
l'amendement mohamed et et théophile qui
consiste à dire vous êtes malade vous ne
pouvez même pas être soigné chez vous
mais restez chez vous c'est exactement
le cas des français résidant à
l'étranger reste et c'est vous alors moi
je demande une harmonisation pour éviter
une inégalité de traitement ce qui se
fait ici dans l'hexagone c'est
l'apparition d'un nouveau variant je
demande la même chose dans les outre-mer
deuxième raison c'est l'efficacité pour
être efficace il faut aller vite lorsque
vous allez constater la possible
saturation du système de santé il sera
trop tard la pandémie sera là la
circulation virale sera renforcée et
bien présente et donc si on veut être
efficace et de dire eh bien pour
l'égalité de traitement éviter de faire
des outre-mer des français entièrement à
part il faut parler de nouveaux variants
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur je regrette que ce soit celui
des amendements de monsieur lurel qui
arrive en premier parce que la
commission a donné un avis favorable à
tous les autres j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure mais pas à celui ci s'il y
aurait des gens suis vraiment désolé
mais nous pensons effectivement que le
bon critère pour restreindre l'accès à
nos collectivités d'outre-mer c'est le
risque de saturation
du système hospitalier pour une bonne et
simple raison c'est que lorsque ce
risque survient il est très graves en
métropole
si vous avez une saturation de l'hôpital
de mulhouse vous pouvez faire des
évacuations sanitaires à strasbourg
nancy metz ou dans d'autres villes si
vous avez dans votre collectivité une
saturation de l'hôpital vous ne pourrez
pas faire d'évacuation sanitaire donc
c'est une mesure de sauvegarde et nous
sommes là encore dans un cas très
exceptionnels je crois qu'il faut s'en
tenir là mais nous allons discuter
d'autres amendements sur lesquels la vie
sera favorable merci la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
michel sénateurs
l'autre amendement vise à aligner les
conditions du pass entre les
collectivités d'outre-mer un territoire
métropolitain sur sept du pass entre le
territoire national l étranger je suis
favorable à ce que l'apparition et la
circulation d'un nouveau variant soient
également prises en compte sur
l'instauration de ce dispositif lorsque
cela s'avère nécessaire sur les
déplacements entre le territoire montre
d'outre-mer pardon les collectivités
d'outre-mer un territoire métropolitain
néanmoins je pense également que le
critère de risque de saturation du
système de santé quand même pertinents
c'est ce critère d'ailleurs sur lequel
nous avons fondé les évacuations par
pont aérien depuis la polynésie il y a
quelques mois en effet le caractère
insulaire des départements d'outre-mer
rend les phénomènes de résurgence
épidémique plus difficilement
maîtrisable s'ajoute à cela une offre de
soins plus restreinte c'est vrai et une
couverture vaccinale souvent moindre
qu'en métropole mais également des flux
touristiques et des brassages de
populations qui peuvent être très
importants pendant l'été le critère de
saturation du système de santé est alors
nécessaire aux côtés de celui de
l'apparition de la circulation d'un
variant pour cette raison je demande le
retrait de votre amendement qui est en
partie satisfaits par l'adoption des
amendements 55 et 65
m'avait demandé la parole
j'avoue que j'ai du mal à comprendre
l'argumentaire de notre rapporteur
je ne veux pas évoquer des situations
personnelles
lorsque on constatera qu'il ya
saturation du système de santé il sera
trop tard à l'époque lorsqu'on là il
sera trop tard lorsqu'on l'a on l'a déjà
vécu on a dû envoyer la réserve
sanitaire on a dû envoyer les armées
mais la circulation était bien là en
plus c'est développé toute une
propagande anti vaccins il était
beaucoup trop tard s'il faut attendre de
constater ce qui existe en permanence
l'insuffisance de los dos que la
saturation parce que permanente dans les
hôpitaux d outre mer il sera trop tard
je dis qu'il faut être efficace et aller
vite et le constater le plus vite
possible voilà ce que je dis c'est pas
plus compliqué que cela ensuite bon on
vient de faire quelque chose l'a ancrée
ne sont de prison sanitaires vous ne
pouvez pas de soigner chez vous vous ne
pouvez même pas de négliger en métropole
je viens un peu cette situation
particulière je le dis très clairement
condamné à rester chez vous vous n'avez
pas de place vous n'avez pas de souhaits
mais le médicament ne l'est pas de
soignants il sera un peu tard moi je
maintiens l'amendement parce que je
connais un peu la situation
mais
tout de même rassuré monsieur lurel on
n'attend pas la saturation c'est s'il ya
un risque de saturation
les autorités sanitaires mettent en
place ce filtrage mais on n'attend pas
la saturation bien sûr vous avez tout à
fait raison quand le système hospitalier
est saturé il est déjà trop tard mais
quand on voit que les chiffres
augmentent rapidement on prend
immédiatement la mesure
merci donc je mets aux voix l'amendement
42 qui a reçu un avis défavorable des
commissions du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 43 monsieur lurel
le président c'est un amendement simple
qui est de nature rédactionnel pour
intégrer toutes les natures d'exécutif
de nos différentes collectivités dans
les outre-mer merci l'avis de la
commission celle rapporte à
un avis favorable
si l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le sénateur je demande le
retrait de votre abonnement au profit de
l'amendement 45 ou que je suis favorable
et qui dans sa rédaction prévoit les
exécutifs locaux
merci
monsieur
lurel vous retirer non vous me demander
la parole invasive non madame la
présidente je ne retire pas les
exécutifs locaux j'ai trente deux
communes il ya à la tête de chaque
commune un exécutif local c'est le maire
j'ai un président de région j'ai un
président de département qui sont
également des exécutifs locaux
et donc si on devait consulter tous les
exécutifs locaux on n'en sortira pas ce
n'est pas efficace je connais pas
l'amendement que vous évoquez monsieur
le ministre mais il me semble que ce
prêt d'actions est simple et on intègre
la guadeloupe qui a deux exécutifs de
collectivités dites majeures chez moi
régions et les départements c'est le cas
de la réunion mais ça peut être
également en mettant le mot territoriaux
le cas de la polynésie la nouvelle
calédonie c'est un autre sujet ils sont
autonomes en matière de santé mais si
vous mettez exécutifs locaux ces vagues
et c'est confus
merci alors donc je mets au voile un
moment 43 qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission et un avis défavorable
du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté l'amendement 58 même la
présidente à ça si
les siècles alors si madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le dispositif choisi par
le rapporteur dans le sahara écriture de
l'article 2 circonscrit la possibilité
pour le gouvernement d'exiger la
présentation d'un certificat sanitaire
de voyage pour les voyageurs ultramarins
en transe sur le territoire
métropolitain
uniquement en cas de risque de
saturation du système de santé en
outre-mer s'il est prévu comme amont de
toute implication du dispositif prévu
l'exécutif de la collectivité concernée
soit consulté nous considérons pour
notre part que ces derniers devraient
être aussi pouvoir être à l'initiative
de toute application
je vous remercie
merci l'avis de la commission sur la
porte un
madame la présidente chers collègues
nous avons inscrit à mon initiative dans
le texte de la commission des lois un
droit de proposition
vous proposer un droit d'initiative
alors là sans faire de juridisme mais je
suis obligé de vous dire que droit
d'initiative et droit de proposition
c'est pas exactement la même chose si on
a des petits votre amendement on ne
pourrait mettre en oeuvre la mesure qu'à
l'initiative de la collectivité avec le
droit de proposition on permet à la
collectivité
j'oserais dire de prendre l'initiative
c'est à dire de déclencher une décision
mais qui ne lui appartient pas qui
appartient aux autorités sanitaires et
je vous propose d'en rester au texte de
la commission qui à mon avis ça tu
satisfait très largement votre intention
vous n'avez sans doute pas entendu
donner à la collectivité le monopole de
la démarche donc si vous voulez bien
retirer votre amendement vraiment la
commission des lois vous en sera très
reconnaissante
merci monsieur le ministre avait du
gouvernement mais ma vie dans ma peau
merci monsieur b vous le retirer merci
beaucoup
d'amendements 45 à monsieur lurel
[Rires]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre un collègue c'est la maman
présenté par notre collègue concorde
bien entendu accompagné par tout le
groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
notre collègue propose
au nom des exécutifs
de donner cette
décision à l'exécutif lui-même
avec la précision convient d'adopter à
l'exécutif lui-même et non plus par
délibération
puisqu'il faut au moins douze jours pour
convoquer une bleyer
alors que un président qui serait
investie de pouvoirs propres pourrait
faire cette demande là et donc pour
l'efficacité là aussi il faut aller vite
c'est ce que propose notre collègue
catherine conconne et madame apprécié
notre site si vous permettez je
présenterai aussi le 44 ça y
est vite elle propose que le premier
ministre répondre dans un délai de dix
jours pour que la chose soit pleinement
efficace
merci beaucoup monsieur orel l'avis de
la commission sur à porter sur
l'amendement 45 si vous voulez vous
donner sur 44 aussi favorable favorable
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
favorable les sagesses madame la
présidente merci beaucoup alors je mets
au voit donc l'amendement 45 qui a reçu
un avis favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il donc adopté
l'amendement 44 a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission et sagesse du
gouvernement c'est pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient et donc adopté
monsieur ménard auch
pro explications de vote
sur l'article 2 1 nous sommes d'accord
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure le régime
j'ai juste signaler que sur l'article 2
chez une demande de scrutin public mais
vous pouvez prendre la parole je vous
remercie
tout à l'heure je l'étais à signaler le
le vote sur l'amendement
consistant à
ajouter le vaccin et les certificats de
rétablissement était une des conditions
du fait que nous puissions ou pas voter
cet article 2 celui aussi sur les
mineurs
jusqu'à 18 ans qui ne devait pas être
soumis on était une autre ces deux
conditions n'ont pas été remplies ce qui
fait que nous ne voterons pas
effectivement cet article de ce n'est
pas la seule raison
il y en a une autre c'est qu'en fait
nous trouvons confrontés à une
problématique qui reste toujours la même
depuis que ces lois nous sommes
proposées c'est que sous couvert d'un
besoin de réagir vite à certains off de
critères bien trop fou vient trop floue
de menaces graves laissée à
l'appréciation bien trop changeantes du
gouvernement et encore quand je dis du
gouvernement sait pas de qui est ce que
c'est le comité scientifique est ce que
c'est le has est ce que c'est en fait le
dernier qui a l'oreille de notre
président ce sont des éléments qui ne
nous paraissent pas des bases assez
prévisible pour laisser l'exécutif
décider seul de mesures si restrictives
restrictives et pénalisante pour les
mineurs on l'a vu qu'ils ont déjà
beaucoup souffert de la crise j'aurais
tendance à dire au gouvernement occupez
vous plutôt de la qualité de l'air des
écoles mais aussi on l'a vu pour les
outre-mer ou ou pour les français de
l'étranger
préparez l'urgence ne justifie pas tout
nous avons par le passé sur le sujet de
la pandémie déjà légiféré en quelques
jours et les mesures urgentes pour la
restriction de liberté d'aller et venir
existe déjà et nous ne pensons pas
nécessaire de donner trop de pouvoirs à
l'exécutif même si c'est pour un mois
avec retour de vol parlement il suffit
de regarder expérience avec l'avènement
du variant brésilien où le ministre des
transports de l'époque monsieur clémot
bonne justifier du manque de
concertation européenne pour maintenir
les vols en provenance du brésil en
assurant que le contrôle du motif
impérieux et du pcr négatif suffisait
suffit aussi de regarder l'argumentation
de monsieur vers en face à l'anxiété des
élus corses la première était sur la
demande de tests négatifs pas efficaces
selon ancien ministe de la sorte et on
vous l'a dit tout à l'heure de nos
collègues ne dessert pas grand chose
mais je voir le diable et donc nous ne
voterons pas cet article 2 merci alors
donc j'ai été saisie comme je les dis
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe l'est républicain sur l'article 2
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 120
sur l'article numéro deux compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au politique
est notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 343 nombre de suffrages exprimés
263 pour l'adoption 236 contre 27 le
sénat a adopté
après l'article 2 j'ai saisi d'un
amendement le 2 rectifié de monsieur
mouillé merci mme la présidente l'objet
du présent amendement est de créer un
comité national de concertation et de
coordination des territoires pour la
lutte contre le commis de 19 nous savons
tous que durant la crise les
collectivités territoriales ont joué un
rôle spécifique et ont montré une
réactivité remarquable pour apporter une
réponse adaptée aux besoins de
concitoyens
aurait été l'amendement du sénateur
richard qui a été votée permet de créer
une nouvelle autorité pour le suivi de
la crise qu vide monsieur le ministre
c'est amendement est donc un amendement
d'appel pour que les associations
représentant des collectivités les
parlementaires soit associé à cette
nouvelle instance je porte ici une
demande forte des collectivités et
notamment de l'assemblée des
départements de france jour merci merci
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est une demande de retrait chers
collègues bien que je comprenne
parfaitement l'intention mais si vous
voulez qu'on passe au vote
je m'en remettrai à la sagesse mais nous
sommes que il ya déjà de multiples
consultations possibles sont d'ailleurs
nécessaire qui n'est pas indispensable
d'en ajouter d'autres
et sachez que la commission des lois est
extrêmement sensible à la nécessité de
prendre en compte l'avis des élus qui
savent la réalité de la situation dans
leur collectivité
l'avis du gouvernement et ses ministres
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur votre amendement
vise à proposer la création d'un comité
national placé auprès de la première
ministre pour associer les collectivités
à la lutte contre le coït 19
je partage votre souci d'associer les
collectivités territoriales aux prises
de décisions en temps de crise sanitaire
même si les décisions à prendre impose
agir avec rapidité et efficacité à la
fois au niveau national mais également
dans chaque territoire autour du préfet
et du directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé des élus et acteurs
de terrain ont été associés mais le
comité que vous appelez de vos voeux
existe déjà sous une forme très voisine
avec le comité de liaison et de contrôle
instituée à l'article 11 de la loi du 11
mars 2020 que le présent projet de loi
maintient dans tous ses éléments pour
cette raison votre amendement me semble
satisfait
merci monsieur mouillé tirer oui
messieurs je retire puisque j'ai évoqué
que c'était dans mon monde appelle
simplement monsieur ministre j'entends
votre argument et c'était amendement a
été rédigé avant la possibilité
d'installer une nouvelle instance de
suivi et donc ma caution sait quel sera
le lien entre ces instances
scientifiques et les collectivités voilà
donc j'aurais souhaité une réponse de la
ministre se dit en particulier je
retiens l'abandonner sans merci alors
nous on passe à l'article de biche et
des demandes de prise de parole et la
première le premier monsieur alain
houpert
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre
hier l'académie de médecine a donné son
avis sur la réintégration des soignants
non vaccinés avançant un risque de perte
de cohésion et de confiance entre
malades et soignants il me semble
inapproprié de parler de confiance alors
que des feux font rage dans plusieurs
régions de france que des femmes et des
hommes son coin orné en pleine rue nous
continuons d'exclure des professionnels
investis pour la sécurité de leurs
concitoyens
alors que l'hôpital est à l'agonie
nous continuons deskur des soignants
alors que alors même que nous avons
autorisé des personnels malades mais
vacciner à exercer auprès des patients
il a été reconnu que le vaccin n'empêche
pas la contamination et la vague que
nous avons connus après la mise en place
du pass vaccinale le démontre
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi
lève le pass vaccinale sur le territoire
hexagonal et 7 enfin monsieur le
rapporteur un souffle de liberté mais
c'est surtout la fin d'un dispositif
injuste inéquitable et parfaitement
contreproductif cet article 2 bis a pour
objet de rétablir un peu de cohérence en
permettant aux agents publics non
vaccinés de réintégrer leur emploi dans
des modalités qui ne constitue pas une
charge supplémentaire pour l'état il en
va de la santé et de la sécurité des
français il en va de la cohérence
scientifique
mes chers collègues pour protéger
l'hôpital nous avons un ferme et des
français aujourd'hui pour protéger les
français nous nous nous nous nous vous
demandons monsieur le ministre de
libérer nos soignants nos forces de
l'ordre nos pompiers 140 professionnels
et 5000 volontaires et nous en avons
besoin
merci la parole à monsieur victorin
lurel
les
collègues
bon ce 2 bis introduit un principe de
réintégration des personnels suspendu
j'aimerais pouvoir dire et redire devant
vous ce soir que je crois à la science à
la médecine et au progrès
le bon de le répéter je suis pour la
vaccination car il sauve des vies c'est
mon seul souci il me plaît de vous dire
de vous redire que je ne suis pas opposé
à la réintégration des personnels
suspendu comment refuser un agent
hospitalier suspendu d'être réintégré
par exemple les jardins d'un hôpital
je me vois mal aller dieu c'est pas
possible bien mais
je reste
opposé le reste opposée elle avait
intégration des personnels suspendu des
soignants non vaccinés au chevet des
malades ou des personnes fragiles et
vulnérables
j'affirme ici de manière comme dirait
césaire autres lucides et conséquente
que je reste opposée à cette
réintégration je reste c'est une
exigence morale
celle de l'exemplarité et de l'éthique
attaché aux soins et je rappellerai et
je n'aurai pas le répéter dans la
présentation de l'argument si j'ai
encore quelques minutes
au niveau national il ya 500 infirmiers
qui seraient suspendus pour deux cent
soixante trois mille infirmières
75 médecins et pharmaciens pour 85 1000e
médecin 200 pompiers sur 40000 vous avez
eu quatre avis puisque le ministre nous
dit je veux un avis éclairé pour objet
iv la situation elle est déjà objective
et puisque vous avez l'avis du comité
scientifique fermement opposés la vie de
l'académie de médecine la fédération
hospitalière de france le conseil
national young et je finis ma dope le
président de la fédération nationale des
sapeurs pompiers voilà merci la parole
est à monsieur georges patient
la vaccination est encore plus
obligation vaccinale pour les personnels
de santé ont été très mal accueillie en
guyane pour ne pas dire plus je crois
pouvoir dire qu'il en a été de même dans
d'autres territoires ultramarins
l'obligation vaccinale en dépit des
violentes contestations a finalement été
appliqué avec les sanctions prévues en
cas de non vaccination
au dernier décompte en guyane il y avait
86 personnes suspendues au no
vaccination les taux de vaccination qui
sont toujours à des niveaux encore fait
satisfaisant entre 75 et 80 8%
aussi l'état des connaissances
progressant tout comme la prise en
charge des malades s'il convient dès
lors de revan réévaluer la pertinence de
l'obligation vaccinale
si l'on estime que le risque n'existe
plus ou du moins qu'il est faible alors
il faudra suspendre la mesure
c'est ce que propose cet article
additionnel
mais c'est également ce que sans vouloir
faire le gouvernement puisqu'il a saisi
sur ce sujet la haute autorité de santé
la semaine dernière monsieur le ministre
cas l'avis négatif de la haute autorité
de santé il faudra néanmoins donner des
perspectives assez personnel quitte très
humaniste imaginer des aménagements de
leurs activités nous ne pouvons les
laisser indéfiniment sans travail
pouvons-nous même de le permettre à
l'heure où nombre de nos services
d'urgence sont en souffrance au moment
où je vous parle je pense notamment au
centre hospitalier de l'ouest guyanais
qui ne fonctionne pas la nuit faute de
personnel suffisant je vous en remercie
mais si même s'ils viennent noël merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme vous
le savez je me bats depuis maintenant un
an quasiment en faveur de l'abrogation
de l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
et des pompiers et je suis heureuse que
ce sujet prennent enfin tout ça passe
dans le débat public enfin car cette
mesure en oeuvre depuis presque un an a
fortement déstabilisé notre système de
soins et de secours face à certains qui
tente de minimiser les chiffres évoquant
que les soignants suspendu ne
représenterait que 0.53 % de nos
effectifs de santé que les pompiers
suspendu ne représenterait que 2 % des
effectifs il combien une bonne fois pour
toutes de rétablir la vérité sur ces
chiffres
très fortement sous-estimés qui ne
prennent pas en compte tous les
soignants qui ont démissionné de la
fonction publique tous ceux qui ont
demandé une mise en disponibilité
tous les professionnels libéraux les
médecins généralistes les sages femmes
les kinés qui ne relèvent pas de la
fonction publique hospitalière et qui ne
sont donc pas suspendu ils sont
interdits d'exercice monsieur le
ministre donne et nous des chiffres de
vrais chiffres alors que notre hôpital
est à l'agonie alors que la france brûle
au sens propre comme au sens figuré nous
nous payions le luxe aujourd'hui de nous
passer de milliers de soignants et de
pompiers qui ont juste voulu exercer
leur libre choix comme n'importe quel
français à l'égard d'un vaccin qui ne
protège ni de la contamination
ni de la transmission du virus il n'y a
plus rien de sanitaires ni de
scientifiques dans tout cela nous sommes
face nous sommes face à une obstination
aveugle dogmatique et idéologique qui
nous conduit dans le mur monsieur le
rapporteur dans ces conditions permettez
moi de juger même si je me réjouis de
votre amendement que votre amendement
traitant de ce sujet est beaucoup trop
timide vous laisser une nouvelle fois la
main au gouvernement pour procéder à
cette réintégration lorsque les
conditions seront réunies pardon mais
c'est à nous députés sénateurs de le
faire et de le décider maintenant cette
obligation vaccinale elle a été mise en
oeuvre par la loi ce qu'une loi peut
faire une loi peut le défaire il ne faut
pas perdre une minute la situation est
trop grave et ce sera donc le sens d'un
de mes amendements merci monsieur le
questeur jean pierre sueur
oui devant eux cette nouvelle
intervention de notre collègue je dois
remercier marie noëlle lienemann qui
tout à l'heure à 10 avec tellement de
force ce que les vaccins importés à la
science la médecine et à la vie tout
simplement de dizaines et centaines de
millions de personnes je crois que c'est
très important de le redire je voulais
intervenir simplement sur une question
qui paraîtra formelle mais je me
souviens du jour funeste où la
conférence des présidents du sénat a
décidé que tous les rapporteurs serait
désormais tenues dans l'exercice de
leurs missions de déclarer devant la
commission un périmètre au sein duquel
on aurait le droit de déposer des
amendements et à l'extérieur duquel les
amendements seraient bannis j'ai
toujours été contre cette procédure qui
est attentatoire aux droits du parlement
qui me paraît d'ailleurs eu poser un
problème constitutionnel
eu égard au droit d'amendement que je
sais qu'il existe l'article 45 et sans
doute at-on voulu prévenir
les décisions éventuelles du conseil
constitutionnel qui est très très rude
sur question est alors je me suis
étonnée je m'étonne aussi en sciences
public que cet article 2 bis qui est le
fruit d'un amendement
soit apparue alors que le texte tel
qu'il nous a été présentée ne permet pas
de traiter de cette question c'est autre
chose alors naturellement j'ai entendu
la réponse de monsieur le rapporteur je
sais qu il la rappelle rappellera ici je
le suppose mais je vous assure que
cet épisode montre tout simplement le
caractère très arbitraire dans lequel on
peut tomber avec ce type de procédure
merci monsieur marc laménie
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président la commission des lois sur le
reporter chars collègues tous les
articles sur important brrr cet article
simplement je souhaitais intervenir
modestement concernant cet article 2 bis
qui fait référence à la loi du 5 août
2021 en n'oubliant pas de rappeler bas
tout le travail qu'a fait la commission
des lois depuis mars e2020 dès le 1er
confinement il ya eu aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de sujets
particulièrement sensibles dramatique et
cette loi qui fait référence à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire loi du 5
août 2021 certes il y à des amendements
et je crois que tous les amendements
sont toujours à la fois intéressant et
qui suscite aussi des débats des
réactions et je crois que méritent aussi
du respect
il ya des serbes des amendements
concernant cet article 2 bis de
suppression il ya aussi et surtout d
amendement qui vise à
réintégrer les agents ou fonction
publique ou autres bien entendu des
personnels soignants suspendu en effet
des milliers de soignants les
sapeurs-pompiers forces de sécurité qui
sont
concernés et qui ont été aussi depuis
plus de deux ans particulièrement très
sollicité beaucoup de collègues ont
rappelé aussi les besoins en personnel
au niveau des hôpitaux de la fonction
publique hospitalière tous les
établissements de soins de santé et
c'est vrai que les sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont aussi et toutes les forces de
sécurité très très sollicités encore
plus en ce moment on est mérite aussi
bien entendu notre respect et notre
reconnaissance
sujet hautement sensible mais d'un souci
eux j'irai 2 essayer de trouver le bon
sens et c'est vraiment très très
compliqué donc
je n'écouterai avec attention les avis
du rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour me pour en le vote concernant cet
article 2 bis merci beaucoup merci même
cécile cukierman oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues tout d'abord et je veux
peut-être le rappeler en préalable je
fais partie de ceux nombreux ici qui ont
toujours été convaincus que le vaccin à
défaut de solder cette pandémie était en
tout cas une arme efficace pour empêcher
sa propagation et notamment le
développement des formes les plus graves
qui ont amené malheureusement un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes soient à
décéder soit à souffrir encore
aujourd'hui de des séquelles et y
compris du côté de long qui n'est
toujours pas reconnue cependant sur la
question des personnels tant de santé
que des sapeurs pompiers
nous mesurons maintenant le temps
faisant la difficulté qui peut d'abord
faire preuve d'une incompréhension le
pass vaccinale n'existe plus il y a donc
aujourd'hui des sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont vaccinés qui sont en possession
d'un schéma vaccinal complet qui
pourtant sont porteurs du virus nous
avons des personnels soignants qui sont
dans la même situation et nous venons de
rappeler monsieur le rapporteur l'a
d'ailleurs précisé que compris à
l'entrée de l'hôpital à l'entrée de
l'hôpital il n'y aura plus de des ehpad
pardon il n'y aura plus de passes
vaccinale demande et donc je crois que
nous avons réellement à réfléchir et la
question n'est pas l'être dans une
vision jusqu'au boutiste mais nous avons
besoin en métropole comme dans les
outre-mers de ces femmes et de ces
hommes de personnel soignant
deux sapeurs pompiers professionnels ou
volontaires pour répondre aux urgences
de cet été alors moi je ne souhaite pas
selon le gouvernement qui décide je
pense à notre parlement justement de
décider comment les réintégrer avec des
tests avant la prise de service sur
certains postes de service plutôt que
d'autres mais en tout état de cause
monsieur le ministre monsieur rapporteur
nous pouvons soutenir cet article tel
que rédigé merci monsieur alain milon
merci la présidente je voulais
intervenir parce que je ne voterai pas
cet article daubisse je voterai
évidemment les amendements suppressions
qui seront présentées par mes collègues
je veux dire simplement plusieurs choses
en voyant cet article j'en ai discuté
avec le rapporteur hier encore je me
suis interrogé sur le personnel médical
et sur le personnel médical non vaccinés
j'ai repris les chiffres de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur en provence
alpes côte d'azur il y a deux chu la
peine marseille lch unissent des gros
hôpitaux tout autour et puis etc etc sur
l'ensemble des milliers de personnels
médical médecins et personnel médical de
ces sanitaires de ces hôpitaux et sur
l'ensemble des personnels soignants des
maisons de retraite nous avons en tout
et pour tout sur la région paca
exactement selon la rs
264 personnel suspendu sur les milliers
de personnes qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux et dans les hospices donc ça
c'est vraiment des gens qui refusent
avec stations et les réintroduire ces
réintroduire des gens qui refusent la
vaccination et c'est donc permettre de
faire un précédent avec des gens qui
lorsqu'ils seront pour être embauchée à
l'hôpital doivent être vaccinés contre
l'hépatite doivent être vaccinés
comptait thanos refuseront ce genre de
vaccination et si on leur refuse
l'entrée dans l'hôpital parce qu'ils
refusent tétanos et l'hépatite désirons
vers un juge et le juge pourra s'appuyer
sur le précédent que vous créez
aujourd'hui donc vraiment comme l'a dit
madame dit hautain dans son intervention
il y à un risque majeur de créer une je
sais pas si le terme exact mais une
jurisprudence en tout cas un précédent
extrêmement important et comment
allez-vous faire après pour les parents
qui refusent la vaccination pour leurs
enfants sur la rougeole pour les refuser
en crèche
ou à l'école comment allez vous faire
pour les parents qui refusent le
papillomavirus la vaccination contre le
palima veut papillomavirus nous créons
un précédent extrêmement dangereux je
voterai contre l'article de glisse j'en
ai évidemment les amendements de
suppression merci cher collègue madame
raymonde poncet monge
merci madame la présidente alors au
moins aussi en préalable un jeu rappelle
que la crise qu vide a poussé le
gouvernement à lancer une vaste campagne
de vaccination
largement suivi qui a permis de sauver
de nombreuses vies bien la vaccination a
été rendue obligatoire pour les
soignants et les sapeurs pompiers mais
nous avons à juste titre ici refusé le
licenciement des personnes qui alors en
poste 1 c'est pas un long gauche alors
on poste refuser la vaccination créant
dès lors un ovni législatives dans le
droit du travail une suspension sans
rémunération pour un motif nouveau
interdisant le licenciement n'obligeant
pas la démission on estimait vous l'avez
dit l'an passé à 15000 le nom des
soignants concerné deux tiers aurait été
réintégrés bien mais que faire de ceux
qui restent ces soignants vont ils
rester suspendue at vitam aeternam sans
vision sur les conditions de leur
réintégration à part la vaccination bien
sûr il faut donc éclaircir les critères
qui justifie de maintenir cette
suspension en fait les mêmes qui du
maintien de l'obligation puisque nous
savons que nous allons désormais vivre
avec l'aco vide les raisons qui nous ont
fait adopter l'article 1a nous
conduisent à poser légitimement cette
question quand faute de soignants quand
même des soignants vacciner mais
contaminés sont autorisés à exercer voir
sont rappelés je suppose qu'on à
examiner le calcul bénéfice risque qu'on
juge alors suffisantes les mesures
barrières il est temps de réinterroger
c'est légitime la suspension encore en
vigueur de centaines d'infirmiers est
toujours impératif est justifiée au
regard des risques nosocomiaux et sur
quels critères ont jugé nous devons
trancher à moins de vouloir punir à vis
des soignants qui ont refusé une sorte
de bannissement j'entends cela un petit
peu chez certains
décidée alors dans ce cas là il fallait
les licenciés il faut être cohérent
messi est décidée sur est seulement de
suspendre sur des raisons objectives la
haute autorité de santé donc doit
d'abord préalablement définis merci
chalifour la transparence sur les
critères et celle de l'obligation qui
veut même si chers collègues la
suspension dans l'air une victoire
jasmin
merci madame la présidente je voudrais à
ce stade attiré l'attention sur les
personnels qui sont vaccinées parce que
ce sont les personnes qui met aussi en
danger parce qu'ils sont pour la plupart
en burn out sur les personnes fatiguées
épuisé pour la plupart donc je pense
qu'il faut aussi humaniser notre
démarche ce sont des personnes qui sont
en souffrance qui ne peuvent pas prendre
leurs congés leur récupération voilà
tout simplement ce que je voudrais dire
merci mais marie noëlle lienemann
oui chers collègues j'entends certains
collègues s'émouvoir des démissions de
l'hôpital public on aurait été terrassé
brutalement l'hôpital n'aurait plus le
personnel à cause des refus de
vaccination j'aurais aimé chers
collègues que vous soyez plus mobilisés
quand avec mon groupe et beaucoup
d'autres nous demandions à l'état de
recruter dans les hôpitaux de mieux
rémunérer les soignants et les
personnels et d'avoir un plan si je puis
dire marshall pour être rapide pour
sauver les hôpitaux
là on vous entendez pas c'était pas
grave si on pouvait s'arranger mais
maintenant il y aurait tout lé monde
hôpitaux des hôpitaux viendrait du fait
qu'il n'y a pas de soignants tel 30
soignants pour refuser la vaccination
mois gestion total accord avec ce qu'a
dit monsieur millon au bout d'un moment
au bout d'un moment
dans un dans notre pays s'il n'y a pas
un équilibre entre le libre arbitre de
chacun la responsabilité qu'il prend
pour l'assumer et la loi générale qui
s'impose à tous et ben nous savons de
beaucoup de souci à nous faire
parce que c'est la crise de l'intérêt
général qui s'exprime
à partir du moment où nous avons décidé
pour des raisons de protection et quand
on est malade soi même on est quand même
plutôt rassurés de penser que les
personnels sont vaccinés même si
lucidement on sait que c'est pas un zéro
risque c'est le principe dit de
précaution
il faut prendre toutes les précautions
possibles même si elles ne sont pas
absolues donc moi je crois que si on
commence à mettre le doigt dans
l'engrenage
que chacun décide que c'est bien fondé
ou pas on peut contester la loi je
comprends certains la conteste pas ce
qu'ils sont pas d'accord ça sert à rien
moi même et moi je crois que nous avons
intérêt à défendre pied à pied les
principes que nous avons en effet la
fonction publique c'est des
responsabilités on assume des
contraintes des libertés et un certain
nombre d'avantagés de statut dont moi je
messiaen vous demande de ne pas accepter
la réintégration des soignants merci
monsieur internet merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues d'abord je voudrais
relayer la demande de chiffres précis
agrégé monsieur le ministre qui vous
avez qui vous a été fait a été formulée
très bien par sylviane noël je crois
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'avoir des
chiffres objectifs qui nous permet
d'avoir une idée de ce que représente
l'effectif réel fonction publique
hospitalière
salariés de droit privé professions
libérales
voulons pompiers professionnels et
volontaires pour qu'on sache vraiment
dans le pays à l'instant où je parle
vous avez les éléments statistiques qui
vous permettent de répondre à cette
question monsieur le ministre mais de ne
jamais dire ah bah tiens on va prendre
un chiffre comme par hasard dans une
danse d'une ars dans le domaine
hospitalier ça donne 200 et quelques
d'après moi j'ai les pompiers ah bah ça
donne 200 et quelques chez les pros en
oubliant qu'il ya 5000
volontaires qui sont qui ne sont plus en
capacité d'être de monter aujourd'hui
dans un vs avez
deuxième chose je remercie le rapporteur
puisqu'avec son amendement il permet
qu'on est que ce débat ait lieu parce
que que je sache je n'ai pas mémoire
nous ayons décidé ici pour ceux qui
l'ont voté pour ceux qui ont voté la
suspension des soignants non vaccinés
que nous les ayons suspendu a dit à mme
aeternam et antoine flahault professeur
de médecine à genève 10 le maintien de
la suspension des soignants non vaccinés
n'est plus fondée sur des preuves
scientifiques
il ya en effet il n'ya en effet pas de
raisons d'exiger le vaccin chez les
soignants car il n'évite pas ni ne
réduit pas suffisamment les
contaminations des nouveaux variance du
sascoc 2 sur un plan éthique il n'y a
pas davantage de raison de ne pas
réintégrer les personnes non vaccinées
par ce qu'il penserait différemment des
vaccinés mais est ce une condition de
leur embauche que d'avoir des
raisonnement scientifique validée par le
gouvernement ne pas réintégrer les
non-vaccinés sans un minimum de foot de
fondement scientifique créerait un
précédent
questionnable en termes de gestion des
fonctionnaires blâmer ses personnels de
santé je cite toujours pour leur
comportement passé irresponsable et
illégale oui c'est flahaut qui parlent
ne pas les réintégrer nom antoine
flahault professeur de médecine personne
qui est énormément intervenu pendant le
bel si chers collègues
donc deux amendements que nous allons
étudier identique et faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune donc et ce sont
des amendements de suppression et le
premier 52 même guillotin merci madame
la présidente alors à nouveau je crois
tout à tout a été dit pour expliquer la
suppression de cet amendement et qui
mirent qui remet en cause le principe de
réintégration d'aidé soignant non
vaccinés déjà c'est une modification du
régime de l'obligation vaccinale qui a
été décidée à un moment où la crise
sanitaire était là on parle bien de
l'obligation vaccinale et la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui on l'a dit tous
dans cet hémicycle n'est pas derrière
nous mais encore en situation d'épidémie
et cette obligation vaccinale des
soignants perdure et je crois que la
moindre des choses pour un soignant
c'est de la respecter
je crois comme certains l'ont dit à la
fois en la science bien évidemment la
médecine mais surtout en l'intérêt
général et je ne pense pas que chacun
dans une société dans un métier dans un
établissement puisse décider de son côté
ci se vaccine où il se vaccinent pas
alors on m'a dit oui mais en fait avant
c'était pas comme ça ou alors pourquoi
séparer intérêts intégré mais moi quand
j'ai fait des études de médecine
plusieurs ici l'ont fait moi si j'avais
pas mon certificat de vaccination contre
l'hépatite b je pense que tout le monde
était pareil eh bien nous ne faisions
pas de stages terre je ne rentrais pas
en médecine ont demandé donc c'est rien
n'a changé en fait dans le système jeu
on a un débat aujourd'hui sur cette
réintégration alors qu' un débat sur le
fait est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
vaccination des soignants est encore
nécessaire
ça c'est un débat qu'il faudra avoir si
elle n'est pas nécessaire eh bien on
annule cette obligation vaccinale est
bien évidemment que les soignants non
vaccinés sont réintégrés mais si la
science la médecine par les autorités
sanitaires et monsieur le ministre va
peut-être nous nous informer des
contacts qu'il a eus mais si cette juste
cette vaccination
vu le contexte sanitaire est encore
obligatoire et mali soignant non
vaccinés ne peuvent pas être en contact
avec des patients notamment les plus
fragiles dans des services de réallouer
c'est que neuf patients sur 10 sont des
patients non vaccinés donc j'en dirai
pas beaucoup plus tout a été dit je vous
remercie madame lienemann d'ailleurs
pour le petit coup de gueule que vous
avez tout à l'heure parce que juste deux
choses c'est pas en répétant des choses
fausses sans cesse qu'elle devienne vrai
merci
l'amendement fois sans comme adam cohen
oui merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues avec cet article 2 bis le
rapporteur propose une issue à la
situation des personnels soignants
suspendu en leur permettant en fait
d'être réintégrés dès lors que la
situation épidémique et pis demio
logique constatée par la haute autorité
de santé ne nécessiterait plus
l'obligation vaccinale pour ses
personnels je veux saluer cet effort de
réécriture de la part du rapporteur
philippe bas il s'agit effectivement
d'une légère avancée par rapport au
texte initial du gouvernement
mais il nous paraît difficile au niveau
de notre groupe majoritairement de
laisser les personnels de santé suspendu
à cette évolué sion qui semble
s'inscrire sur le long terme et moi je
pense que le débat là devient plus
intéressant parce qu'il est moins
binaire je pense que en tout cas je fais
partie de ceux qui trouvent en que la
vaccination c'est une arme efficace pour
combattre effectivement cette pandémie
même si ça a été dit c'est pas suffisant
mais en tout cas c'est une manière de
protéger les personnes et patienter et
les patients mais on sait également les
limites au niveau de la contamination
et puis là quand on parle des personnels
mes chers collègues on s'attaque quand
même au droit du travail et ça c'est une
première si je puis dire c'est à dire
que est ce que ces personnels qui sont
des des personnels de santé qui sont des
pompiers est ce que finalement ils vont
être intégrés ou ces îles sont suspendus
advitam eternam
ça c'est pas possible
et en même temps on nous dit oui mais
c'est important ils doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités
mais est-ce que vis-à-vis de toutes les
responsabilités sont prises quand on
demande au personnel soignant alors
qu'ils ont le qu'ovide d'aller
travailler parce qu'il manque du
personnel là on ne s'occupe pas des
problèmes de contamination
là on ne s'occupe pas de leur santé donc
on veut pas faire deux poids deux
mesures et il me semble important de
dire aujourd'hui que y compris continue
de la situation de nos hôpitaux des
établissements publics de santé il est
important de réintégrer ces personnels
je vous remercie merci l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente
les amendements dont il est question ici
porte sur la suppression d'une
disposition adoptée
par la commission des lois qui ne
prévoit pas la réintégration des
personnes non vaccinées
je tiens à le dire parce que la plupart
des interventions qui ont eu lieu
était soit contre la réintégration
soit pour la réintégration ce n'est pas
de ça qu'il s'agit vous pourrez
d'ailleurs renouveler votre prise de
position dans un instant par qu'il y à
bien des amendements qui exige selon des
modalités différentes d'ailleurs la
réintégration je n'ai pas proposé la
rétrogration à la commission des lois la
commission des lois n'a pas adopté
d'amendements
procédant à la réintégration
le sénat a voté l'obligation vaccinale
le sénat a également voté la suspension
d'activité des personnels soignants
principalement qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés dans le but de protéger les
malades des personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées en établissement
médico social je tiens à ce que les
choses soient claires
parce que c'est ainsi qu'elle se
présente
mais à la différence des vaccinations
qui sont nécessaires pour l'accès à la
fonction publique hospitalière
la vaccination contre le coc vide est
une vaccination temporaire les
personnels qui n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner n'ont pas été licenciés
leur lien avec le service public
hospitalier ou avec une clinique ou un
établissement médico social privé n'est
pas rompu
la suspension du contrat de travail est
par définition temporaire et non
définitive que tous nos collègues qui
pense qu'on pourrait ne jamais
réintégrer ces personnels lesage bien le
droit applicable avant la proposition
adoptée par la commission des lois
exclu qu'il reste suspendue pendant
toute la vie si on avait voulu les
écarter définitivement de leur métier
pour des raisons qui tiennent à une
sorte de morale qu'un personnel soignant
ne devrait pas refuser de se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils exposent des
patients un risque que tous ses
collègues sache bien
que cette exigence morale tout à fait
respectable qu'il voudrait voir imposer
n'est pas dans le droit positif
actuellement applicables donc tous ont
vocation à reprendre un jour leur
travail est ce que nous proposons nous
ne devons proposer qu'il le reprenne
maintenant
je réponds non
est ce que nous devons prévoir les
conditions dans lesquelles le
reprendrons je réponds oui et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que la commission des lois
a fait parce qu'actuellement c'est un
pouvoir discrétionnaire du gouvernement
ne pouvons faire confiance au
gouvernement ou ne pas lui faire
confiance en tout cas sa liberté
d'action est totale et nous avons pensé
face à un sujet qui effectivement ne
concerne pas de nombreux agents
mais un peu plus de 2000 c'est à dire
très peu d'argent à l'échelle de
l'emploi de plus d'un million de
personnes au sein du service public
hospitalier et des cliniques privées eh
bien ces quelques centaines de personnes
elles ont droit à des égards l endroit à
ce qu'on s'occupe d'elle
on n'a pas voulu qu'elle contamine la
cause est entendue mais enfin elles ont
une vie une famille un revenu à acquérir
par leur travail il est bon d'organiser
leur retour et de ne pas laisser ce
retour à la discrétion du gouvernement
nous voulons que une décision médicale
s'impose au gouvernement et c'est la
seule chose que nous ayons décidé alors
nous avons dit je pense que c'est
pertinent que c'est la haute autorité de
santé qui prendra la décision de dire ça
y est enfin libre le coc vide c'est fini
l'obligation vaccinale n'a plus de sens
pour le coc vide et puisqu'elle n'a plus
de sens le lendemain monsieur le
ministre vous serez en tort si vous ne
prenez pas le décret autorisant la
réintégration et pour être sûr que cette
haute autorité de santé
se prononce
au moment opportun et que les choses ne
traînent pas dans la situation se sera
absolument améliorer nous disons que la
haute autorité peut s'autosaisir que le
gouvernement peut la saisir que le
nouveau conseil qui se substituera au
conseil scientifique peut la saisir mais
aussi que les commissions des affaires
sociales de nous deux assemblées
auxquelles je crois monsieur alain
millon qui s'est exprimé tout à l'heure
peut faire confiance comme nous tous
pourront saisir la haute autorité de
santé c'est tout rien de plus et rien de
moins et c'est déjà un pas en avant pour
dire à ses personnels moi je pense
qu'ils ont eu tort de ne pas se faire
vacciner mais il avait la liberté de ne
pas se faire vacciner car on ne vaccine
pas de force en france
en revanche nous avons voulu mettre à
l'abri les malades les personnes âgées
les personnes handicapées et donc ils
n'ont pas pu rester au contact de ceux
ci pas plus que les pompiers qui
actionne les secours d'urgence et par
conséquent
nous sommes maintenant je crois dans une
situation je le dis très sobrement où il
y a un chemin vers la réintégration de
ces centaines d'agents qui n'ont pas
reçu une punition mais qui se sont vu
imposer de ne pas faire prendre de
risques aux malades et aux personnes
vulnérables ni un chemin nous le créons
mais nous le créons pas de manière
fantaisiste en disant scrogneugneu je
décide aujourd'hui mois
sénateurs de les réintégrer parce que
ceci n'a pas de sens
je crois que la décision doit être
médicale elle le sera et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous demande de rejeter
la suppression de notre article
2 bis et puis tout à l'heure je voudrais
demanderait également de rejeter la
réintégration ce le souci d'équilibré de
mesures dont on a une certaine pratique
au sénat
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il est
minuit passé alors je vous propose de
prolonger notre séance afin d'achever
l'examen de ce texte
je ne vois pas d'observation il en est
ainsi décidé
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la commission des lois a retenu un
dispositif équilibré sur les conditions
d'une levée le moment venu de
l'obligation vaccinale
facilitant notamment la saisine de la
haute autorité de santé pour se
prononcer sur son bien-fondé
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
transparence je donc être transparent
sur les derniers chiffres en ma
possession concernant le secteur
sanitaire
2605 suspension de personnel soignant et
non soignant parmi ces suspensions 75
médecin trente deux sages-femmes
608 infirmière six ans une aide
soignante et 50 de kiné
l'avis du gouvernement et donc
défavorable à la suppression de cet
article introduit par la commission des
doigts
merci alors avant de donner la parole
pour explication de vote je voulais
juste informé l'assemblée que j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public à
part le groupe l'est républicain
la parole à monsieur théophile
la ministre mme sheikh collègues je
voulais pas intervenir sur ce sujet
puisque ce sujet a fait de gros dégâts
de très gros dégâts chez nous et qui
continue je suis de la guadeloupe
je sais que 94 à 95% des soignants sont
vaccinés chez nous yves et son delta
mais je raisonne en ratio ratio de taux
de chômage il y à peu près 180
personnes à 200 personnes qui sont
devant le chu
et qui ont décidé de faire en fer
domicile depuis quelques mois
c'est toute la guadeloupe à peu près qui
passe le matin devant le chu pour soit
donné à manger
soit laissé quelques 10 euros pour que
ces personnes puissent eux en tout cas
s'occuper de leurs enfants
pendant la période électorale
et vous savez chez nous 200 personnes ça
touche rapidement toute la guadeloupe
ils ont décidé les guadeloupéens de
faire la peau de tous ceux qui ne
soutenaient pas eh bien les suspendus
faire la faire la politique c'est devenu
un sujet national tout ce qui était et
qui prônait l'art
la non réintégration des soignants ont
été battus et ça c'est un pan deuxième
chose je parlais du taux de chômage eh
bien ces personnes là ne travaille pas
et n'ont pas de revenus et c'est ce qui
rythme la vie aujourd'hui en guadeloupe
ce que je demande pourtant je suis un
défenseur du vaccin étroit et très
rapidement
j'étais président de la fédération
hospitalière des antilles et de la
guyane
je connais comment ça se passe je suis
je suis rationnelle ce que je demande
c'est qu'il y ait et c'est une
proposition un biais pour que ces
personnes là qui ne travaillent pas
puissent trouver le moyen d'avoir une
activité dans le cadre d'une activité
d'intérêt a dit faut qu'ils puissent
toucher au moins un revenu et le temps
viendra ils vont intégrer toucher leur
salaire puisqu'il ne sont pas licenciés
mais ils n'ont pas fait de l'europe au
gris qui fut se trouver une alternative
a lâché le nier merci
merci madame la présidente moi je
souscris au fait qu effectivement même
si certes cet article 2 bis était voté
aucun soignant ne sera réintégré à court
terme parce que tant que l'épidémie
continuera et des vagues sont à venir et
bien l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants sera maintenu et cet article 2
bis ne propose pas de réintégrer des
personnes alors que l'obligation
vaccinale est en vigueur donc
effectivement
il faut être cohérent si on veut que ces
soignants reprennent leur travail il
faut soit levé l'obligation vaccinale et
je n'ai pas entendu qu'il en soit
question soit sinon à battre à battre
une valeur fondamentale de l'engagement
dans un métier de soignant qui est
d'accepter de se plier à des règles de
protections collectives de solidarité
réciproque au-delà de son propre choix
individuels et si cette porte est
ouverte eh bien les dégâts seront
considérables
dans notre société
confronté à cette question
il eût été plus sage de s'en tenir au
dispositif actuel qui prévoit que par
décret après avis de la haute autorité
de santé l'obligation vaccinale puisse
être levé et donc logiquement les gens
être intégrés mais le rapporteur a
choisi d'étendre le champ du projet de
loi
on verra bien éventuellement ce que le
conseil constitutionnel en dira pour
traiter cette question
ça n'apporte rien de plus ce n'est qu'un
message politique qui est envoyé et qui
prend que place et patrick kanner l'a
dit dans le cadre des nouveaux
équilibres politiques de nos assemblées
et nous avons même assisté aujourd'hui
dans notre hémicycle un retrait par le
groupe qui soutient toujours le
gouvernement d'un amendement contre
l'avis du gouvernement mais pour faire
passer
texte avec la majorité l ère du sénat
pourquoi pas mais il faut le dire
clairement ce n'est pas une posture
scientifique ou autre c'est un choix
politique
merci monsieur chassang
donc je mets dans le sens de ce qu on
aime dire bernard jomier si vous voulez
la réintégration du personnel ne peut
pas être fait tout de suite d'ailleurs
elle sera faite par la parle hs si
l'évolution de la situation
épidémiologique le justifie donc c'est
pas du tout pour pour l'instant mais en
fait je voterai l'amendement de madame
guillotin vernet guillotin pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez on retrouve on
retrouve à l'article 12 de la loi du 5
août 2021 le point cap qui permet au
gouvernement par décret après avis de la
chaise de réintégrer tout ou partie des
soignants non vaccinés alors ce qui
après avoir voté l'article 2 bis pourra
être fait par la chaîne mais déjà ça
peut être faible dans le cadre de la loi
du 5 août 2021
alors donc comme je vous l'avais dit
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe l'est républicain
sur les amendements identiques
même lebron oui merci madame la
présidente je ne serai pas très longue
mais concernant le personnel soignant
dans ce ce mot qui englobe soignants et
il ya des personnels administratifs
on a tous rencontrés des personnels
administratifs des hôpitaux des centres
médico sociaux qui sont aussi touchés
par l'interdiction d'exercer or ils ne
sont pas en contact avec les malades moi
je on a reçu par exemple des
pédopsychiatres qui qui travaillent avec
les établissements scolaires qui
prennent les enfants dans une salle de
20 mètres carrés et qui sont à distance
d'un enfant alors que cet enfant va être
avec 30 autres enfants dans une salle de
classe les enseignants n'ont pas
l'obligation de se faire vacciner et
pourtant ils sont avec beaucoup
d'enfants donc il ya quand même des
professions dans ce set globalité du
personnel soignant qui pourrait être
remis au travail sans danger et tout le
monde n'est pas à achever de quelqu'un
qui est en réanimation n'y a absolument
aucune logique et aucun bon sens à
suspendre quelqu'un qui est du personnel
administratif travaillant dans un
établissement hospitalier hospitalier au
médico social je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir à ça aussi merci merci
vraiment monsieur le rapporteur très peu
de temps parce que si vous voulez passer
la nuit avec moi il n'y a pas de souci
mais en revanche
ce sera
à votre détriment il a fallu
il a fallu madame la présidente
allez-y il a fallu madame le président
en attendant le jour de mon anniversaire
que vous ayez des paroles aussi suave à
vos oreilles
et je tiens à vous en remercier
publiquement
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais simplement dire à notre
excellente collègues que nous avons
pensé au cas qu'elle vient de signaler
puisqu'il est prévu dans notre texte
que les l'obligation vaccinale pourra
être levé par catégorie successives de
personnel effectivement la haute
autorité de santé pourra très bien dire
que telle ou telle catégorie de
personnel parce qu'elle est éloigné des
personnes vulnérables
on peut lever son obligation vaccinale
plutôt que pour d'autres
madame kerman
mes chers collègues malgré l'heure
tardive et et ricanements tout d'abord
je crois que cette question est
éminemment politique au sens
étymologique du mot à savoir comment est
ce que nous faisons société ensemble et
notre collègue théophile a dit avec ses
propres mots mais nous ne sommes pas
simplement sur une question à savoir
combien de personnels soignants sont
aujourd'hui interdits d'exercer leur
profession est suspendu nous ne sommes
pas aujourd'hui à savoir quel est le
ratio de personnes qui pourraient être
des sapeurs pompiers qui ne sont pas
nous sommes dans une question qui est
nous n'allons pas rouvrir le débat ici
je vous rassure monsieur ministre et mes
collègues
qui résultent de comment la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire et de la situation
vaccinale a été fait et discuter ici au
parlement comme dans le reste de la
société
donc l'on pourrait se renvoyer autant
que de besoin qu'il s'agit d'un monde
finalement marginal de personnes nous
pourrions vous dire comme ça a été fait
qu'il y à un nombre
très important de profession qui
aujourd'hui sont en contact avec le
public sont des vecteurs de transmission
qui ont vécu cette septième vague à
l'heure où les masques sont tombés et
qui pour autant eux n'étaient pas soumis
à une obligation vaccinale
et donc ce n'est pas simplement une
question
anecdotique ou de décret à venir je
crois que c'est très sincèrement
aujourd'hui comment est-ce que certains
se sentent d'abord exclu à tort ou à
raison je ne reviens pas sur ce que j'ai
dit précédemment
et comment est-ce que collectivement
nous allons réintégrer l'ensemble de ces
personnes pour continuer de faire
société ensemble et de servir l'ensemble
de la population
nous voterons bien évidemment notre âme
ans non merci donc nous allons procéder
donc au scrutin public qui était
demandée par le groupe l'est républicain
sur les amendements identiques 50 de
rectifier 60 rectifié je vous rappelle
que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable à vis du gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin public aura lieu
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 121
sur les amendements identiques numéro 52
rectifié quoi de terres et 60 rectifier
et compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs groupe politique est notifiée
à la présidence nombre de votants 338
nombre de suffrages exprimés 334 pour
l'adoption 104 contre 230 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
alors nous passons à l'examen des
amendements suivant le 1 rectifié madame
noël
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
comme évoqué tout à l'heure mon
amendement a pour objet de réintégrer
immédiatement
les soignants et d'abroger sans tarder
cette obligation vaccinale petite
précision mes chers collègues lorsque je
remets en cause le fait que le vaccin
puisse protéger de la transmission et de
la portabilité du virus je ne remets pas
en cause son efficacité sur sa
protection contre les formes graves
voilà je me sens véritablement attaqué à
chaque fois et je pense que cette mise
au point elle est essentielle regardons
nous nous avons tous repris aujourd'hui
une vie normale on a plus de masquer les
gestes barrières on les a un petit peu
mis de côté donc oui on est de nouveau
dans une petite vague voilà d'épidémie
de cas mais encore une fois ce ne sont
pas forcément des cas graves est
aujourd'hui le coc vide ils tuent
environ
j'ai regardé les derniers chiffres ça se
tient c'est entre 50 et 70 personnes par
jour sachez juste que le cancer tue
entre 350 et 400 personnes par jour on
peut donc considérer qu'on est quand
même rentré dans une phase endémique et
que les conditions me semble aujourd'hui
réunies si elles ne sont pas réunies
aujourd'hui quand le seront elles elles
ne le seront jamais parce que si on
attend qu'il n'y ait plus de pression
sur les hôpitaux vu l'état dans lequel
sont nos hôpitaux malheureusement on
n'en sortira jamais donc faut quand même
aussi se souvenir qu'il ya
quasi totalité des pays dans le monde
qui ont levé cette obligation vaccinale
des soignants est-ce qu'on va être le
seul sur la planète à le maintenir
bref dans mon département je tiens quand
même à apporter mon témoignage
bon nombre de ces soignants et de
pompiers sans perspective d'avenir ont
d'ores et déjà opté pour une
reconversion dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité ou alors dans certaines
régions frontalières comme la haute
savoie ils sont tout simplement partie
en suisse il faut que sa publication
conclure qu'elle n'est pas requise donc
vraiment je vous demande véritablement
elle soutenir cet amendement merci merci
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur
je suis défavorable tout comme la
commission des lois à ces amendements
j'ai précisé à madame noël qui a comparé
le nombre de morts du cancer au nombre
de morts dus qu'aux vide actuellement
qu'il ya du point de vue de la
vaccination des personnels une
différence c'est que qu'on ne peut pas
contaminer un malade du cancer ou plutôt
une personne
faisant qu'elle soit affectée par le
cancer
si on n'est pas vacciné tandis qu'on
peut éviter de contaminer
à malades
de l'hôpital par le cos vite si on n'est
pas vaccinée c'est cette comparaison n'a
pas tellement de sens voilà ce que
j'essaye d'expliquer à cette heure
tardive de notre débat en tout cas
l'avis est défavorable ainsi l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie me dans le président merci
alors pour expliquer addition de vote
monsieur je me
oui madame la présidente merci parce que
malgré l'heure tardive on peut pas
laisser dire dans cet hémicycle des
choses qui sont totalement fausses et
oui parce que le vaccin n'annule pas la
transmission mais la réduit et ça n'est
pas rien la réduction de la transmission
ça n'est pas inintéressant on va le
répéter à chaque fois que vous avancerez
des faits qui sont inexactes mais nous
nous sommes effectivement pas dans des
dispositifs efficaces à 100 % et nous
personne n'a prétendu
que les vaccins éviter 100% des formes
graves et 100% des transmissions c'est
un outil un parfait mais c'est le
meilleur qu'on est jusqu'à aujourd'hui
puis deuxièmement il a tué ce virus
depuis le début de l'année 25 mille
personnes sur les six premiers mois ça
fait pas 70 par jour je vous invite à
sortir votre calculette ça fait deux
fois plus
il tue il a tué du 1er janvier au 30
juin on verra plus tard pour les
chiffres du 17 juillet si ça vous amuse
mais 25000 personnes ça veut dire une
moyenne de cinquante mille par an et
l'on a tué sans ce sens il a tendu et
150000 français depuis le début de la
pile l'épidémie ça en fait un des
problèmes de santé publique majeur de
notre pays au même niveau que le tabac
l'alcool ou la pollution de l'air alors
minimisé sans cesse les chiffres
minimisé l'intérêt des outils de lutte
je me demande quel est le fond de tout
ça qu'est-ce que vous poursuivez comme
but de nier de nier la nécessité qu'une
société adopte des mécanismes collectifs
pour se protéger contre une menace de
sanitaires de premier ordre et ben moi
ça me laisse pantois parce que eh oui
parce que vous vous êtes simplement la
défenseure du mois jeu et je ne veux
aucune contrainte et je balaye et je
minimise sans cesse la réalité et vous
ne pouvez pas le nier c'est bien
cinquante mille décès annuels sur la
pente sur laquelle on est en ce moment
merci madame goy chavent
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre sur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
on est quand même dans une sacrée
hypocrisie
faute de soignants faute de pompiers ont
somme ces gens d'aller au travail
malades du que vides enfin il faut quand
même ici que quelqu'un le dise on
l'essonne d'aller travailler parce qu'on
a plus de personnel oui des infirmiers
et des infirmières en réanimation c'est
pas la peine de dodeliner des infirmiers
et des infirmières en réanimation malade
du coeur vite vont au chevet de leurs
patients il faut quand même que
quelqu'un le dise ici
donc moi je dre savoir pourquoi se
priver de ses personnels
franchement il vaut mieux qu'ils aillent
travailler sans être malade avec
éventuellement un test pcr avant plutôt
que des personnes vaccinées parce qu'ils
sont vaccinés à et quand même travaillé
malades fiévreuse enfin quand même
il faut ouvrir les yeux moi je sais pas
je suis effaré de cette discussion
j'attends monsieur le ministre votre
réponse solennel dites moi pourquoi vous
acceptez que des personnels soignants et
des sapeurs pompiers soient obligés
d'aller travailler alors qu'ils sont
souffrants du coc vite
merci monsieur joyandet
mais merci vers la présidente c'est pour
soutenir monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président l'amendement de cydia noël
également parce que ya une chose que
l'on sait aujourd'hui on essaie de
prendre des décisions par rapport à la
situation d'aujourd'hui pas par rapport
à la situation d'hier on sait
qu'aujourd'hui
le vaccin ne protège pas en tout cas pas
beaucoup delà de la contamination
première chose deuxième chose on sait
qu'il ya pas de hasard dans les grand
nombre il n'y a pas de hasard dans les
grand nombre et à partir du moment où on
sait très bien qu'à aujourd'hui
énormément de contamination ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya aujourd'hui
énormément de soignants de pompiers de
d'autres personnes qui travaillent en
ayant en ayant le coc vide qu'ils se
sont d'ailleurs pas testé donc il ya
effectivement une situation
d'aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait prendre en
compte parce que entre quelqu'un qui est
vacciné malades du code vide qui
travaillent est quelqu'un qui ne peut
pas travailler parce qu'il n'a pas été
vaccinés et quand on sait que cette
vaccination ne protège pas c'est
peut-être le moment justement de
d'accélérer un peu sur le retour des
agents dans leur service au moment où on
a le plus besoin et puis moi je pense
pas franchement que ce soit une question
de chiffres bonne question de nombre
c'est une question de principe dans la
société on peut peut-être se dire qu'à
un moment donné on les a exclus parce
que vous n'avez peut-être pas tous les
éléments ou peut-être fallait-il le
faire à ce moment-là mais si les
éléments ont changé est-ce qu'on laisse
et citoyennes et les citoyens comme ça
sur le bord de la route dont un certain
nombre non plus de salaire depuis des
mois et des mois alors qu effectivement
je confirme ce qui vient d'être dit
d'autres citoyennes et citoyens qui sont
malades qui ont le corps vide et vont
travailler avec un masque donc c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut y réexaminer la
situation et c'est peut-être aujourd'hui
qu'il faut avancer sans pour autant
attendre que le gouvernement prenne une
décision sous une autorité quelconque
dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
laquelle ce sera un
merci madame miller bronn
merci madame la présidente moi je
voulais juste préciser que le taux de
survie au qu'ovide c'est
99,8 % au pire donc on parle on parle
pas des veaux là on parle pas du parle
du pire 99 8 % de personnes survivent au
co vide je vais le préciser aussi que si
on pense que au bout d'une troisième
dose de vaccin
elle est valable quatre mois puisque au
bout de quatre mois il faut recommencer
bien les plus personnelles vacciner
aujourd'hui dans quatre mois ne l'est
plus il n'est plus considéré comme avoir
un schéma vaccinal complet donc est-ce
qu'on remet ce personnel en cause on
sait que dans les hôpitaux aujourd'hui
parce que il y a besoin de personnel les
chefs d'établissement n'oblige plus à la
troisième ou à la quatrième dose sinon
ils ont plus personne donc c'est
malhonnête c'est malhonnête
et peut-on devons nous rester dans une
décision qui est aujourd'hui injustes et
malhonnêtes
merci monsieur opère
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues devant la
mort il faut être humble devant la
maladie il faut être humble arrêtons de
nous battre avec des chiffres nous
sommes face à une injustice
à une inégalité
face à des gens qui n'ont plus de
travail qui n'ont pas la possibilité
puisqu'ils sont toujours intégré d'aller
chercher un autre travail
un peu d'humanité
hospital l'hôpital ça veut dire ça vient
d'hospitalité un peu de spiritualité
merci alors je me
suis fier mais monsieur fialaire s'avoue
j'entends parler d' humilité je crois
qu'il en faut un petit peu d'humilité
effectivement j'entends parler aussi de
principe je crois qu'il en faut des
principes on a vraiment un problème dans
notre société de respect de l'autorité
et un manque d'autorité lorsque papa de
l'autoritarisme les choses mais d'une
autorité de compétence alors on peut
dire que l'académie de médecine ce
qu'elle dit n'importe quoi les facultés
de médecine c'est n'importe quoi nos
autorités de la santé c'est n'importe
quoi on peut citer un professeur moi je
pourrais citer le professeur raout aussi
bien qu'ils étaient une sommité faut
arrêter je pense que dans une société
dans notre république qui prône aussi la
solidarité la la fraternité faut avoir
en respect de certaines règles
si on respecte pas minimum de règles si
on ne les fait pas respecter si on n'est
pas exemplaire quelle image on donne à
l'ensemble de nos sociétés à nos enfants
aux simples citoyens qui font confiance
lorsqu'ils vont dans des services de
soins pour recevoir justement des soins
qui sont peut-être pas
exactement
ce que l'on souhaiterait mais qui qui
sont l'objet de consensus le fruit de
consensus scientifique et qui ont été
approuvés alors effectivement un peu
d'humilité s'il vous plaît et puis un
respect de certains principes et celui
du respect de l'autorité
merci jeu mais je mets au voile
amendement numéro 1 rectifié qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 35 que monsieur
durel
madame la présidente monsieur michel
collègues j'ai bien entendu les
explications de notre reporter
les personnels aujourd'hui suspendu
n'ont pas vocation à le rester à des
ternes âme ils ont bien vocation à
réintégrer leur travail c'est la raison
pour laquelle je n'ai pas voté la
suppression de cet article 2 bis en
revanche manger un autre problème si le
contrat de travail n'est pas suspendu
j'ai un problème d'affectation et j'ai
un problème de respect et de discipline
d'autorité
évoqué il y à un moment de discipline
quelque part oui à la réintégration mais
non à l'affectation chevet des malades
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
propose un moyen terme de dire si cette
vocation est bien là ils peuvent
réintégrer leur travail et sud d'accord
pour l'heure la réintégration mais non
pas à leur affectation au chevet du
malade ou des personnes fragiles ou
vulnérables je vois mal comment un
directeur d'établissement
ne pourrait pas réaffecter alors je
viens la personne a subi une formation a
subi une
une obligation à respecter une
obligation vaccinale pour entrer dans le
métier il me semble je parle sous votre
contrôle qui lie à 72 métier éligibles à
l'obligation vaccinale il y à une seule
dose est une vocation plus que
professionnelle helvétique elle est
morale c'est de dire que vous devez
prendre soin de vos patients et donc moi
je propose que au lieu de laisser à la
seule discrétion du gouvernement on peut
faire confiance ou de laisser à une
haute autorité de santé ou à je ne sais
quelle autre machin quelles que soient
leurs expertises concept au législateur
de dire à cette autorité réglementaire
que oui d'ores et déjà nous respectons
cette autorité là nous respectons cette
morale là et que nous excluons une
affectation au chevet du malade elle est
le centre l'amendement qui vous est
présentée
il avait la commission sur important est
défavorable madame le président si
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre la vie madame le président
merci je vais donc aux voix l'amendement
numéro 35 qui a reçu
quand je commence le vote avait fallu
réagir avant donc je vais vous laisser
la parole mais je vous le dis je vous le
dis quand je démarre l'opération de vote
c'est fini je sais donc merci pour ce
que
j'aimerais comprendre l'explication en
quoi le pouvoir d'un directeur c'est
diminuer celui serait impossible puisque
le contrat de travail n'est pas rompu
devrait affecter en quoi en quoi elle et
ça permettra aux gens de retrouver leurs
oeufs travail emploi c'est impossible
d'avoir une explication plus qu'un bon
que je j'ai compris il faut aller vite
mais moi je ne me pose pas la
réintégration je m'oppose à une
affectation j'avais du malade
alors je me vois donc
l'amendement 35 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
ses contres qui s'abstient n'ont pas
adopté flamand 16 monsieur et l'incarner
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues alors cet
amendement qu'on pourrait considérer
comme un amendement de repli après le
rejet des différents amendements
notamment d'amendements de sylviane noël
c'est un amendement qui ne se pose qui
ne ce site place pas sur le débat de
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants qui
ne remet pas en cause la rédaction
proposée par notre rapporteur et la
commission mais qui
parce que la situation actuelle
l'exigent parce que notre département la
haute-savoie et dans une situation des
sanitaires ou
l'aspirateur de ressources humaines vers
la suisse est déjà extrêmement puissant
que cette interdiction faite aux
soignants d'exercer leur métier en
france les conduits directement vers des
employeurs suisses
parce que cette règle là n'existe pas
n'existe plus en suisse
et que cette réalité elle est
transposable dans tout un tas de deux
départements à besançon dans des grandes
agglomérations dans le monde rural moi
je pense que le temps est venu de la
réintégration immédiate des soignants
dont je touche pas à l'obligation
vaccinale on touche pas la rédaction du
rapporteur philippe bas mais de manière
mécanique et juridique cet amendement
permet dès la promulgation de la loi que
les soignants non vaccinés ou qui ne
sont pas à jour de leurs obligations
vaccinales soient réintégrés
ça permet de dépassionner le débat
d'être plus juridique mais je pense que
maintenant le temps est venu le débat
ait été utile je crois qu'il était utile
et merci monsieur le rapporteur de
l'avoir permis j'espère monsieur le
ministre que si vous ne réintègre pas
les soignants non vaccinés que vous
aurez que ça que vous arriverez dans les
mois qui viennent a trouvé un
argumentaire avec une initiative pour le
faire
alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur malgré
l'ingéniosité de cet amendement est
peut-être à cause de cette ingéniosité
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur
ministre même à vis dans le présent
merci
alors j'étais
donc je mets une fois que c est moi
commence à être un peu fatigué donc je
mets au voile amendement numéro 16 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre un qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public à part le groupe l'est
républicain sur l'article 2 bis donc il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
sun ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
t'as du scrutin numéro 122 sur
l'arctique numéro 2 bis compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs go politique
est notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 339 nombre de suffrages exprimés
319 pour l'adoption 229 contre 90 le
sénat a adopté
trois amendements après l'article 2 bis
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune
alors le 63
madame cohen même qu elle oui merci
madame la présidente je vais être rapide
puisque nous avons donné nos arguments
qui plaident pour la suppression de cet
article
et là nous essayons
de poursuivre notre chemin en proposant
donc un amendement où on dit que pour
permettre la continuité de la prise en
charge des patients et pallier notamment
les urgences qui sont réelles du fait de
la situation dramatique que nous vivons
ne manque de personnel de fermetures de
lits etc même si c'est pas la radiation
la suspension des personnels qui en est
là la cause nous demandons donc leur
réintégration ça c'est le l'article le
proclamant
63 rectifié 10 et je vais vous faire
gagner du temps madame la présidente je
vais proposer le 69 rectifié bis si vous
me le permettez tout aussi rapidement
c'est un amendement de repli et nous
proposons également la réintégration de
ce personnel mais en imposant une
condition et cette condition c'est de
justifier d'un tests virologiques
négatif à chaque prise de service donc
c'est aussi une ouverture merci madame
la présidente
maxi alors de un amendement est un
sous-amendement donc l'amendement 23
malades r braun
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors en
plus des soignants hospitalier il y a
environ 1350 professionnels de santé
libéraux des médecins des
kinésithérapeutes des cardiologues des
gynécologues etc qui sont interdits
d'exercer pour le non respect de
l'obligation vaccinale
selon les chiffres donnés par
l'assurance maladie en novembre 2021
alors que les zones qualifiées de
déserts médicaux augmente y compris dans
les grandes villes il est urgent de
supprimer cette obligation vaccinale
dont on connaît maintenant les limites
s'agissant de la transmission du virus à
tout cela ça ne suffit pas encore et
pour décourager encore ces professions
médicales qui manque cruellement de
candidats eh bien depuis quelques
semaines on assiste à une véritable
pratique de chasse aux médecins organisé
par les directions régionales du service
médical ou par les caisses primaires
d'assurance maladie en effet celle ci
signale à l'ordre des médecins les
praticiens et les met met en cause leurs
prescriptions et les liens qu'ils ont
avec leurs patients ils sont convoqués
devant des dessus de ceux d'autres
tribunes al tribunaux par dont sont
l'objet de représailles sont suspendus
ou sanctionnés par des interdictions
d'exercer
jusqu'où irons nous nous avons besoin de
tous nos médecins et des médecins
libéraux aussi et les médecins sont là
pour soigner et non pas pour être
sanctionné merci
merci
souvent sous amendement 71 monsieur
klinger
merci madame la présidente
il y un peu plus de deux ans du jour au
lendemain les soignants et assimilés
comme les pompiers ont dû s'adapter pour
tenter de contrer ce nouveau virus qui
était lakovic 19 nous étions alors en
guerre et tous ont répondu présent les
français chaque soir applaudissent m
leur héros
entre temps le gouvernement établissait
une liste de professions soumises à
l'obligation vaccinale
aujourd'hui la plupart d'entre nous
avons repris une vie normale face à ce
virus et pourtant les pompiers demeurent
soumis à cette obligation vaccinale
alors même que nous savons que la
vaccination n'empêche pas la
transmission du virus alors même que
dans nos territoires touchés par la
désertification médicale un pompier
volontaire non vaccinés peut faire la
différence dans la prise en charge d'une
urgence vitale alors même que nous
sommes les témoins d'un incendie d'une
exceptionnelle force qui ravage certains
de nos territoires
aujourd'hui le gouvernement continue
donc de préférer de rappeler des
personnels vacciner mes malades ducobu
que de faire appel à des professionnels
non vaccinés négatif
cessons d'avoir une vision punitive
ayons une réflexion pragmatique on parle
ici de 140 pompiers professionnels et de
5000 sapeurs pompiers volontaires
cet amendement vise donc à supprimer
l'obligation vaccinale pour les pompiers
et ainsi permettre à tous d'être utile
et d'être sur le terrain pour répondre à
leur vocation première
protéger les biens et secourir les
victimes
merci alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
sur l'amendement 63
rectifié bis l'avis de la commission est
défavorable c'est un amendement qui
prévoit que les directeurs réintègre
c'est-à-dire doivent le faire les
personnels soumis à l'obligation
vaccinale
sur l'amendement se sentent 9 rectifier
la vie est également défavorable
cet amendement pour sa souche
prévoit que les directeurs n'ont pas
réintègre mais peuvent réintégrer les
personnels
soumis à l'obligation vaccinale qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
et les deux amendements sous-amendement
sont également rejeté par la commission
des lois le premier 23 rectifié bis
parce qu'il exonère les médecins
libéraux de l'obligation vaccinale
est le suivant de notre collègue
christian klinger parce qu'il dit que
les pompiers n'ont pas non plus une
obligation vaccinale désormais or c'est
beaucoup trop générale alors chers
collègues s'agissant des pompiers n'a
pas suffisamment parlé ce soir et je
crois que il était important que votre
amendement soit là pour nous donner
l'occasion de le faire mais à ma
connaissance
il n'y aurait que entre 100 et 200
pompiers pour toute la france qui aurait
refusé de se faire vacciner si vous
voulez démentir ce chiffre apportez-nous
effectivement une information que je
n'ai pas pu trouver j'ai en réalité des
informations qui proviennent de sources
syndicales je reconnais qu'elle ne sont
pas d'une fiabilité totale mais
peut-être avez-vous mieux à proposer en
tous les cas je ne crois pas que nous
soyons privé de nombreux
sapeurs-pompiers pour faire face aux
urgences du moment et notamment à c'est
terrible les incendies de forêt de la
gironde et de la bretagne voilà pourquoi
les les avis de la commission sont
défavorable à ces amendements et
sous-amendement même si l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie mais dans le président merci
alors je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 63 que reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
l'amendement 69 même avis même vote
merci le sous-amendement
71 donc
ces mêmes même avis est-ce que
ces mêmes votes
même vote très bien et l'amendement donc
23 mai ma vie même vote
merci beaucoup alors un article 3 les
prises de parole madame muller bronn
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
alors l'article 3 demande au
gouvernement une évaluation du cadre
juridique en vigueur pour lutter contre
les pandémies sans avoir recours à un
régime d'exception ce cra ce cadre
juridique est essentielle pour ne plus
recourir à des mesures d'état d'urgence
mais il devra aussi s'étendre à une
évaluation des décisions médicales et
sanitaires
après deux ans d'absence totale de
transparence sur les expertises qui ont
défini la stratégie de vaccination
l'opacité continue sur le sujet des
effets indésirables en effet 25%
d'effets indésirables graves sont
confirmés par l'asn
ce qui est beaucoup plus que tout autre
traitement ou vaccin normalement on
aurait suspendu la prescription ou la
vente de tels traitements à ce sujet je
veux revenir sur la question que j'ai
posée lors des es 10 des auditions de
l'eau ps c'était en mai dernier au sénat
concernant la vaccination de 22 mille
quatre cent quatre-vingt dix enfants de
0 à 12 ans et notamment de 4500 12
enfants de 0 à 4 ans hors autorisation
et avec des doses adultes parmi eux des
enfants de moins de 5 ans
4512 avec une dose et 2435 avec 2 210
puce disposer d'études cliniques ni
d'autorisation légale
l'asm
répond qu elle réceptionne tous les
signaux envoyés sans distinction d'âge
ou de situation et que toute déclaration
est suivie certes mais tout effet
secondaire at il été déclaré
comment cette cohorte d'enfants est elle
suivit fait elle l'objet d'un suivi
spécifique et pourquoi ce régime
d'exception sur cette cohorte que
peut-on me répondre à ce sujet merci
merci madame angèle préville
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues puis de deux ans après
le début de la pandémie le constat est
quelque part gramat dramatique il a eu
cent cinquante mille morts et comme le
rappelait mon collègue bernard jomier au
rythme de certainement cinquante mille
morts par an et
cela sans que une certaine forme de
cérémonie d'hommage national qui aurait
pu être une initiative opportune
d'autant plus que nombreux sont nos
concitoyens affectées d'autant plus
qu'il a été parfois qu'ils ont été
parfois dans l'impossibilité de vivre
ces deuils dignement notamment au début
de la pandémie malheureusement d'autres
souffrances touche certains de nos
concitoyens à savoir le coc vie de long
il s'agit d'une particularité spécifique
au vide 19 nous n'avons jamais connu ça
avant nous sommes devant une situation
inédite et visiblement nous n'avons ni
suivis ni l' accompagnement adapté à
cette affection de longue durée qui
déjoue tous les schémas habituels j'ai
été interpellé par des concitoyens qui
vivent des situations d'impasse de
véritables errance médical au bout d'un
suivi qui avait pourtant bien commencé
mis en place mais qui s'arrêtent d'une
certaine manière brutalement car il n'a
pas été tenu compte du caractère très
particulier de ces affections qui sont
d'une grande complexité qui nécessite
plus de temps de prise en charge déjà
qu'ils présentent une multitude de
symptômes différents et des thérapies
qui ne sont pas encore cristallisé il
faudra sans doute du temps en tout état
de cause je déplore que l'amendement que
j'avais déposé qui demandait un rapport
et qui a été déclarée recevable sur ce
sujet là sur l'évolution de la prise en
charge et diverses mesures mises en
place pour l'accompagnement de ces
qu'ovide l'on n'ait pas été n'ai pas pu
être examinés et ce soir j'ai bien vu
qu'il avait une feuille de route publiée
17 mars 2022 mais j'ai cru comprendre
que certaines de ses dispositions ne
serait pas appliquée car j'ai dans mon
département d comme je le disais tout à
l'heure des des patients qui sont en
déshérence total et la matière scolaire
merci
madame victor jasmin
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je voudrais ce stade attirer
votre attention sur les conséquences de
certaines des mesures qui ont été prises
il y à un centre de radiologie aux
abymes en guadeloupe un dira pasquin a
pas tant que ça qui est fermée avec
l'ensemble de son personnel et cela pose
un véritable problème pour la prévention
concernant les cancers du sein parce que
c'est un centre qui faisait une bonne
partie des dépistages concernant le
cancer du sein donc on voit loupe il ya
de grandes difficultés parce que de
certaines conséquences de ces fermetures
d'entreprises parce qu'il suffit il
suffit d'après les modalités de cette
mise en place du texte du mois de d'août
dernier eh bien
il se trouve que les patrons quand ils
ne sont pas vaccinés et bien c'est toute
l'entreprise qui ferment voilà donc le
centre de radiologie farrow a dû gages
aux abymes est fermée et ce sont les
épices âge qui sont vraiment en grande
difficulté les femmes aux particuliers
merci alors nous allons passer l'examen
de l'amendement numéro 10 à monsieur
benarroch
merci madame la présidente
la loi du 11 mai 2001 de prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a autorisé la
création temporaire de deux fichiers de
traitement de données à caractère
personnel les fichiers side up et
contacts qu'ovide la centralisation la
consultation de ses données de santé
contenant plusieurs mentions à caractère
personnel ont fait partie intégrante de
la gestion de l'épidémie ces deux
dernières années ces fichiers ont été
maintes fois prorogé sans que nous ayons
pu évaluer l'impact effectif de ces
fichiers de traçage sur la stratégie
sanitaire globale les auteurs du présent
amendement demande donc à ce qu'une
évaluation du cadre juridique dick de
ces fichiers soient réalisés afin de
définir notamment si les protections
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
du droit au respect de la vie privée
sont respectés et si les risques de
pérennisation de ces outils de traçage
de la population dans notre droit commun
merci l'avis de la commission sur un
porteur
madame la présidente monsieur benarroch
c'est montrer aussi convaincant cet
après midi devant la commission que ce
soit devant l'hémicycle c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons émis un avis
favorable
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même à vivre dans le présent merci donc
je vais vous voit l'amendement de m au
disque a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui est content qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté je mets aux voix
l'article 3 qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient donc adopté article
additionnel après l'article 3
l'amendement numéro 8 monsieur
benachenhou
la présidente le présent amendement pour
objet de rétablir l'article 4 du présent
projet de loi adopté en commission à
l'assemblée nationale
et qui avait pour objet d'en joindre le
gouvernement a présenté au parlement un
rapport d' analyse de l'efficacité et de
coût des mesures prises par le
gouvernement sur la propagation de
l'épidémie ainsi que leur impact sur le
système de santé sur l'état de santé de
la population sur l'adhésion de la
population à la vaccination à la cofidis
et sur l'état général de l'économie et
des finances publiques après plus de
deux heures de gestion de l'épidémie de
kobe 19 ils sont fondamentales d'établir
au bilan sur l'efficacité et le coût des
mesures prises dans ce contexte d'autant
plus qu'un autre grand regret le
parlement n'a été que trop peu associés
à ces décisions bien sûr l'argument des
ans ce texte que nous avons voté ne pèse
en fait pas grand chose face au refus
systématique de partage des informations
en particulier les avis et les notes du
conseil scientifique
ni face à la volonté du gouvernement de
ne pas intégrer des propositions qui
n'était pas issu du gouvernement il est
plus que temps d'en faire un ordre des
côtes de permettre aux transparences de
faire un véritable retour d'expérience
et de mesurer avec lucidité et humilité
les mesures que ce gouvernement a porté
lors de sa gestion de la crise sanitaire
du déterminer celles qui ont été
bénéfiques de quantifier ses bénéfices
celle qu'il aurait été dans une moindre
mesure voire de
pointer les erreurs commises comme celle
par exemple de la gestion des masques
que récemment une décision du conseil
d'état a mis en avant dans la prise en
compte des spécificités territoriales ou
la consultation des élus locaux un bilan
présenté devant le parlement semble
également tout à fait nécessaire au vu
de la persistance de l'épidémie de
convives 19 de son caractère épisodique
et du développement de ces variants
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
l'avis est défavorable massive du
gouvernement sioniste
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur dames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur votre
amendement vise à prévoir un rapport
exposant les mesures prises par le
gouvernement aux fins de lutter contre
la propagation de l'épidémie 2019 qui
analyserait l'efficacité le coup et
plusieurs des impacts de ces mesures si
ce rapport était présent dans la version
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
il ne figure plus actuellement dans le
texte adopté par votre commission des
lois il est vrai que plusieurs rapports
ont d'ores et déjà été portée à
l'attention du parlement sur les mesures
de gestion de crise sanitaire en
présentant un bilan de l'application de
ces mesures conformément à ce qui était
prévu par la loi cela étant je m'en
remets à la sagesse de votre assemblée
pour déterminer la nécessité d'un tel
rapport
alors je me vois donc l'amendement de
weeds qui a reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission en avides de sagesse du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
s'abstient pas adoptée alors amendement
47e rectifie madame conway mouret
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues notamment non demande au
gouvernement un rapport
alors je sais que c'est pas la demande
la plus populaire mais j'espère que mon
argumentaire vous convaincra du bien
fondé de la demande qui permettrait au
parlement non seulement d'avoir une
vision globale des diverses mesures qui
ont été prises à destination des
français établis hors de france depuis
le déclenchement de la crise sanitaire
mais surtout de tirer des leçons de leur
efficacité dans le souci d'améliorer ce
qui a été mis en place et d'éviter de
reproduire des erreurs cette pandémie a
obligé tous les états à prendre des
mesures sans pouvoir en évaluer toutes
les conséquences puisque la situation
était inédite deux ans et demi plus tard
le temps est venu d'effectuer un retour
d'expérience afin d'être à même
d'anticiper et de nous préparer aux
crises à venir et malheureusement je
crains qu'elle ne soit nombreuses sur le
plan sanitaire de nombreux français
résidant à l'étranger en particulier
hors de l'espace schengen sont restés
dans le flou pendant de longs mois
exigences d'un motif impérieux pour
entrer en france finalement annulé par
le conseil d'état non reconnaissance des
qr codes délivrée par leur pays de
résidence difficulté parfois à trouver
sur place un accent reconnu par l'europe
sur vaccination prête en conformité avec
le droit local et laura français jusqu'à
cinq ou six injections en un an pour
certaines personnes au delà ce sont tous
les pans de la vie de nos compatriotes
qui ont été impactés pour les aider les
moyens importants ont été engagés des
aides ont été alloués bien que tous les
crédits n'est pas toujours été dépensés
l'abbé feu a aussi soutenu son réseau et
accompagner les familles toutefois les
critères d'accès aux aides sociales se
sont avérées très restrictif de
multiples entreprises françaises n'ont
pas pu se relever des familles se sont
vus dans la capacité de s'acquitter des
frais de scolarité conséquemment à la
perte de leur emploi et de leurs revenus
nos instituts et nos alliances
françaises ont souffert tout comme nos
postes diplomatiques et consulaires
quand accumulé du retard entravant
encore aujourd'hui les démarches
administratives essentiel de nos
concitoyens nous avons fait de
nombreuses interventions qui sont restés
jusqu alors sans réponse pense que un
rapport exhaustif nous éviterait
pléthore de courrier et de questions à
venir contre une grasse semblerait ainsi
l'ensemble des données on est terminée
madame la présidente c'est beaucoup
l'avis de la commission le rapporteur
de la commission comme vous le savez
très attentive
la situation des français de l'étranger
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle a
examiné avec beaucoup de réflexion cet
amendement mais il nous a paru poser un
problème de principe cher collègue c'est
que l'évaluation des politiques
publiques
c'est une prérogative constitutionnelle
essentiel du parlement et la déléguée au
gouvernement en lui demandant un rapport
d'évaluation d'une politique publique ça
nous paraît être un renoncement pour nos
droits qui voudrait beaucoup mieux qu'au
sein des commissions compétentes vous
plaidiez la même cause et que nous nous
en parlions de cette question que vous
soulevez à juste titre de l'évaluation
de
l'efficacité
[Musique]
et
l'impact et du coup dans les différents
domaines que vous citez de la lutte
contre le coc vide
en ce qui concerne naturellement les
français de l'étranger donc voyons des
choses très clairement faisons en sorte
que le sénat assume ses responsabilités
sans les délégués au gouvernement avis
défavorable
si l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
ministre
gouvernement s'en remet à la sagesse de
votre haute assemblée merci beaucoup
donc je mets au voile amendement de 47
oui
mais d'ici monsieur
si vous faites course ne sera pas à ce
serait très couru en plus cette heure au
sujet madame la présidente je profite à
la faveur de l'examen de la boîte bonne
pour collecte pour adresser une demande
des pouvoirs une supplique aux au
ministre de la santé
personne ne sait quel le nombre de
suspendus de soignants suspendu en
guadeloupe en mai dernier
la rs a publié un chiffre qui n'est pas
vérifiée 631
suspendu
et à peu près une centaine qui
n'auraient pas fait de choix et qui
serait aujourd'hui suspendu pourriez
vous demandez à votre ars de publier des
chiffres clairs et puis d'avoir la
pédagogie de la communication s'il vous
plaît je le dis pour que vous
l'entendiez et que vous passiez les
instructions merci merci alors j'ai donc
je mets au voile amendement 47 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission à vis de ça j'ai du
gouvernement qui est pour
ses contres qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté
24 de madame lillers brawn
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors à
travers cet amendement il s'agit de
demander dans un délai de trois mois à
compter de la promulgation de la
présente loi un rapport que le
gouvernement présente devant le
parlement consolidée sur les effets
indésirables des vaccins contre lacko
vite 19 incluant une comparaison
avec les vaccins contre la grippe
ce rapport répond à l'obligation
inscrite dans l'article r 41 27-35 du
code de la santé publique qui prévoit
que le corps médical doit aux patients
une information loyale claire et
appropriée appropriées sur son état
les investigations et les soins qui lui
propose il répond également aux
principes de consentement éclairé
consacré par le code de nuremberg gh en
1947 en présence d'un risque inconnu et
d'une technique vaccinale toujours en
phase d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché conditionnelle dont les études
n'inclut pas la troisième et la
quatrième dose comme le souligne le
rapport d'étape de l'opus cst
l'opex pardon merci publié le 9 juin
2022 sur les effets indésirables des
vaccins contre lacko vite 19 et le
système de pharmacovigilance une
communication transparente et complète
est nécessaire sur l'existence d'effets
indésirables ainsi qu une action
vigoureuse pour encourager les
professionnels de santé à déclarer des
événements indésirables mais aussi un
soutien adapté au système de
pharmacovigilance dans son ensemble pour
garantir les conditions de la confiance
des citoyens dans la capacité des
autorités sanitaires à assurer leur
sécurité
merci oui merci je pensais vous fassiez
le suivant donc comme c'était aussi une
demande de rapport voilà l or à travers
cet amendement à compter de la
promulgation de la présente loi et afin
de procéder à une analyse de la
mortalité toutes causes confondues en
fonction du statut vaccinal des
personnes les données du système
national de données de santé sont rendus
accessibles de manière anonyme is et à
la recherche scientifique pour
l'ensemble de ses acteurs en effet en
moyenne 70% des personnes entrées à
l'hôpital et déclaré qu vides sont
vaccinés
ce sont les chiffres de la drees qui
sont en accès libre la direction de la
recherche des études de l'évaluation et
des statistiques qui dépend des
ministères de la santé et des finances
mais il serait intéressant d'en
connaître beaucoup plus l'âge le sexe
des personnes les dates de vaccination
les marques et les numéros de lots de
vaccins utilisés les dates d'injection
afin de bénéficier d'un référentiel de
comparaison et enfin la date de décès
des personnes toutes ces données
existent dans le système national des
données de santé mais elles ne sont pas
accessibles en toute transparence à la
recherche scientifique voilà l'objet de
cet amendement il servirait de preuve
définitive de causalité
et viendrait appuyer les remontées de
pharmacovigilance merci merci l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
moment sur l'amendement numéro 24 de
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
est là justement on est déjà dans les
travaux pratiques vous les avez vous
même site et l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques est en train de faire le
travail faisons lui confiance
il
incarne justement
la responsabilité la mission
d'évaluation des politiques publiques du
parlement n'abdiquons pas de nos propres
responsabilités en demandant des
rapports que d'ailleurs il faut le dire
le gouvernement n'est jamais tenu de
produire même quand nous avons
voté la demande d'un rapport mais nous
n'avons pas le droit de faire des
injonctions gouvernement en revanche
nous avons le droit et même le devoir
d'évaluer les politiques publiques et
s'agissant de votre deuxième amendement
c'est de 25
rectifier il concerne l'accès des
chercheurs au système national des
données de santé sur la mortalité
relatives au statut vaccinal mais en
vérité cet amendement est satisfait par
le droit en vigueur c'est le sixième man
de l'article l neil 461 tirer 1 du code
de la santé publique c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous demanderai de
retirer ce deuxième amendement sinon de
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
mais ma vie madame la présidente merci
beaucoup donc je mets au voile
amendement 24 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
défavorable
défavorables
vent défavorable donc et pour
sûr le 24
non mais madame la baronne je lance
voilà et on a les avis donc le 24
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement donc pied pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient voilà donc
il est donc pas adoptée et sur le le 25
avis défavorable c'est de la commission
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient pas
adopté
passons à l'amendement 59 mcqueen oui
merci madame la présidente depuis deux
ans le gouvernement a pris des mesures
restrictives de liberté allant d'un
confinement de ce strict de la
population à la limitation des
déplacements en passant par un couvre
feu le soir mais à aucun moment ce même
gouvernement n'est revenu sur les
origines du problème le manque de lits
d'hospitalisation dans notre pays et la
pénurie du personnel soignant pire il y
a eu une politique qui a consisté à
fermer des délits pendant cette crise
sanitaire
5700 en pleine pandémie et 17 me lit
d'hospitalisation
depuis l'élection du président maquereau
en 2017 après l' alerte fin mai 201
services d'urgence le président de la
république a confié à monsieur le
ministre de la santé pas encore ministre
à l'époque la réalisation d'un rapport
flash sur les urgences ce rapport a
formulé quarante et une préconisation
mais malheureusement aucune n'a suggéré
de tirer les conséquences des fermetures
de lits d'hôpitaux en france due
notamment au manque de moyens c'est ce
que nous demandons une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui avec cet amendement nous
savons bien ces fermetures de lits
d'hôpitaux s'inscrivent dans une
cohérence une logique gestionnaire qui
dépasse la simple question de la
pandémie et de ce dernier quinquennat
bien que celui ci ait empiré la
situation
nous avons donc besoin plus que jamais
de pouvoir tirer un bilan de cette
politique
l'argument opposable de ne pas voter des
rapports de la commission ne tiendrait
pas puisque notre haute assemblée avait
voté la remise de ce rapport en juillet
dernier et nous en étions très
satisfaits
hélas cet amendement a terminé sa course
prématurément commission mixte paritaire
nous comptons cette fois ci sur le
rapport de force favorable au sénat pour
que cet amendement une fois votée
dépasse le stade de la cmp soit
définitivement adoptée afin de faire
évoluer les choses et d'enrayer les
rouages du sacro-saint lean management
que le gouvernement entend poursuivre
dans la gestion de notre système
hospitalier public
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
il est défavorable madame la position
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même à vivre dans le présent merci
beaucoup
même quand même
non je veux bien que leur soit tardive
ou au contraire et si qu'il soit très
tôt mais on est en train de parler quand
même d'un sujet qui est extrêmement
préoccupant on peut changer d'avis
effectivement mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi majoritairement notre haute
assemblée avait trouvé juste et efficace
d'avoir la possibilité d'avoir ce bilan
de pouvoir mesurer les conséquences des
fermetures incessantes de lits
d'hospitalisation qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui et nous sommes alertés par
les personnels soignants et là nous dire
bah finalement nous non sans du tout
comment contre-arguments dire ben non
défavorable à cet amendement qu'est ce
qui se passe pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
veut pas tirer de bilan alors qu'il y a
quelques mois on était prêts ensemble à
voir ces données me semble que quand on
fait des choix politiques il est
extrêmement important d'en mesurer les
conséquences et d'avoir des données
précises c'est que ce que nous demandons
travers d'un apport ne vont pas aller
plus loin contenu effectivement des
contraintes qui nous sont imposées vous
le savez très bien monsieur le
rapporteur
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix la
maman 59 cas reçu un avis défavorable à
comme celui du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est donc
pas adoptée et comme vous aimez les
rapports je vous conseille l'excellent
rapport qui vient de sortir sur
l'application des lois où vous pourrez
retrouver justement le taux du nombre de
rapports qui sont effectuées par le
gouvernement y compris sur les rapports
des gouvernements mais je vous laisse le
livre est intéressant
alors je vais passer à l'amendement
numéro 52 monsieur le questeur sueur
et bien madame la présidente monsieur
mini chers collègues à cette heure
tardive
je voulais saluer la sagesse la
modération la prudence et le réalisme du
gouvernement qui a parlé de veille et
sécurité sanitaire finalement c'est
assez clair alors monsieur le rapporteur
a voulu faire un peu de sel joue un peu
peur mais tron le dire en nous proposant
projet de loi mettant fin au régime
d'exception créés par pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
le seul problème c'est que ça ne met pas
tout à fait fin au régime d'exception
puisqu'il reste le cidep il reste le
contact qu'ovide ainsi que le pass
frontières et quelques autres choses
donc nous pensons que c'est finalement
plus réaliste d'en revenir aux têtes au
titre du gouvernement enfin on ne va pas
passer la nuit là dessus mes chers
collègues
l'avis de la commission gérin par terre
madame la présidente le sujet d'une
grande importance symbolique il mérite
bien qu'on passe chers collègues un
moment pour en discuter je suis sûr que
les autres collègues de l'hémicycle
apprécieront ce débat entre questeur
je voudrais vous dire sur collègues
s'agissant des titres des projets de loi
et des propositions de loi d'ailleurs
qu'on pourrait
écrire des romans avec
mais qu'il vaut mieux ne pas le faire
car ce serait souvent des romans triste
s'agissant du titre qu'avait reçu le
gouvernement je crois qu'il ne disait
pas l'essentiel
s'agissant du titre que la commission
des lois adoptées je crois qu'il ne
couvre pas de manière exhaustive la
totalité des articles du texte mais il
est vrai qu aucun titre ne peut couvrir
de manière exhaustive toutes les
dispositions d'un texte il doit donc se
concentrer sur ce qui est fondamental ce
qui est fondamental est qu'ils résultent
d'ailleurs de travail que nous avons
conduit ensemble surtout des bancs cet
après midi et ce soir c'est que si ce
texte est adopté à la suite d'un accord
en commission mixte paritaire promulguée
par le président de la république
dès le jour de sa promulgation
c'est la liberté retrouvée pour les
français la confiance dans leur esprit
de responsabilité pour limiter les
risques de contamination
le retour à l'état du droit
d'avant le coc vide la fermeture d'une
parenthèse la biennale fallu accepter de
l'ouvrir cette parenthèse mais elle sera
fermé et il ne reste plus à titres
résiduels et virtuels que
deux dispositions permettant de faire
face pendant quelques mois encore à
l'irruption d'un problème majeur
sans pouvoir établir que jamais le pass
vaccinale le pass sanitaires le
confinement le couvre-feu l'interdiction
de réunions publiques l'interdiction de
rassemblements et de manifestations
l'interdiction de sortir sans masque
voilà la réalité et donc c'est
simplement par eux honnêteté
intellectuelle compte tenu de ce qu'est
la nature même de ce texte une fois
transformé en profondeur par le sénat
que nous avons décidé de vous proposer
mais la commission des lois propose
le sénat dispose
que nous avons décidé de vous proposer
de changer le titre pour dire qu'il met
fin à cette période d'exception et qu'on
rentre maintenant et nous étions
impatients que ce soit le cas un jour
dans le droit commun c'est très
important
si l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
sagesse nous sommes à présent merci
alors je mets au voit donc l'amendement
50 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission en ami de sagesse du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
non mais il et puis là il et puis la
main alors voilà
vous voulez que je remette au
fait merci alors je m voit l'ensemble du
projet de loi y at il des oui alors
votre monsieur chassaing
qui madame la présidente nous avons
besoin
maintenant le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur nous
avons besoin de contrôler les voyageurs
nous avons besoin de poursuivre les
vaccinations du reste des vaccinations
qui ont très peu d'effets secondaires
et ça va être l'heure de la quatrième
dose pour que notre pays puisse
poursuivre la vie avec le co bidc
variant sans que les hôpitaux les
réanimations
soient submergés avec des ehpad
sécurisé et notre économie maintenant
alors bon j'aurais souhaité que mon
amant
avec la possibilité de présentation pour
les voyageurs de l'un des trois
documents du pass sanitaires je rappelle
tess coït vaccin rétablissement bas
selon le droit européenne soit accepté
et favoriser la vaccination nous aurions
souhaité aussi que la chasse dans
l'article 2 bis informe est clair le
gouvernement qui devrait à notre sens
décidé mais bien sûr l'important c'était
quand même de rétablir l'article 2 même
avec un seul test qu'aux vie et je
suppose que la chaise prendra des
décisions en synergie avec le
gouvernement en ce qui me concerne donc
je voterai ce projet de loi et les
sénateurs mon groupe s'abstient non
merci
merci je vous indique simplement qui
aura un scrutin public demandée par le
groupe l'est républicain
son ensemble du texte monsieur benarroch
féminisme sur le rapporteur madame la
présidente notre groupe s'abstiendra sur
ce texte certes un certain nombre
d'avancées par exemple sur le
positionnement dans le texte d'une raie
à l'abrogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire exprimé clairement à l'article
le début de la fixation d'un cadre
juridique sur une possible fin de
suspension des soignants ou l'obligation
de repasser devant le parlement au bout
de moi nous paraît ce salutaire pour
autant la rétrogration de réintroduction
de certificats de voyages limité à la
présentation de test négatif et ce y
compris pour les mineurs ne nous paraît
pas équilibrer les critères même pour
restaurer des restrictions nous sommes
trop floue hélas une fois de plus trop
de marge d'appréciation au gouvernement
nous n'avons pas oublié les
tergiversations du gouvernement face aux
warriors brésilien nous n'avons pas
oublié la sourde oreille face aux
demandes des élus corses au moment de
leurs hôpitaux et c'est saturé nous
n'avons pas oublié les mesures
différenciée qui avait été prise par
exemple entre le ter et le tgv
l'absence de critères objectifs de mise
en place de restrictions aussi
importante que celle d'aller et venir
vont contre nos idées de dialogue
poussée entre l'exécutif et le
législatif
car nous savons les différer vite vous
nous y avait déjà forcé monsieur le
ministre donc les excuses de l'urgence
ne nous convient pas de manière plus
grave ce texte vous présente rien sur la
qualité de l'air aux prévisions par
exemple de la rentrée rien sur
l'encadrement des masques du prix des
masques ffp2 rien sur l'avenir de la
campagne de vaccination qui pour le
deuxième rappel est vraiment à la traîne
rien sur la gratuité élargie de tests
pcr obligatoires
aussi nous nous abstiendrons à regret de
n'avoir pu au moins discuter d'un
certain nombre de mesures que d'andrew
pas pu proposer depuis près de deux ans
et que certaines décision
d'irrecevabilité nous ont empêché de
défendre ici
merci monsieur le questeur sueur
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
pour nous il ya un point central c'est
que l'article 2 soit rétabli c'est une
question de responsabilité
il était irresponsable de le supprimer
cela dit nous avons connu un certain
nombre de déceptions
qui font que si nous ne nous opposerons
pas ce texte nous ne pourrons le votée
telle quelle c'est pourquoi nous nous
abstiendrons pour trois points
essentiellement
premièrement le report dans les faits de
la clause de revoyure au 30 juin
2003 alors que l'assemblée avait voté le
31 janvier
deuxièmement le fait que pour la
possibilité de contrôler au plan
international et je salue d'ailleurs la
position qui a été celle de monsieur le
ministre
notre assemblée et choisi de restreindre
les modalités du contrôle aux tests
excluant la vaccination ce qui pose un
véritable problème alors que nous avons
tellement militer les uns et les autres
sur l'ardente nécessité de la
vaccination enfin
sur la question de l'article 2 bis nous
considérons qu'il a été introduit de
manière artificielle
qu'il ne règle pas le problème qui est
posé et qu'il aboutit à une sorte d'app
ory de telle manière qu une fois que la
question se posera plus elle le est
censé ne pas se poser il s'agit pas de
réintégration comme l'a dit d'ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur toujours est il
que cela n'apporte rien de positif donc
mes chers collègues pour ces raisons
nous nous abstiendrons dans l'espérance
que la commission mixte paritaire qui
aura lieu demain permettra de nouvelles
avancées qui nous qui nous permettront
de revoir notre vote en lecture
posté merci madame la présidente je vous
en prie merci m présidente à ça si oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur donc
nous nous apprêtons à nous prononcer sur
ce onzième texte de mesures sanitaires
dans un contexte où je préfère le dire
le rapport de force entre assemblée
nationale et sénat et désormais
différent je pense qu'il est nécessaire
de le préciser
pour aujourd'hui et pour les textes à
venir quand je pense que cela a du sens
alors monsieur le rapporteur nous
propose un texte réécrit qui vit et qui
est
bien plus acceptable que la version du
gouvernement
mais d'une part certaines mesures bien
qu'amélioré perdure le passage du ter
est en supprimer mais restant en suspens
si la situation empire variable envieux
dangereux émergents et système de santé
saturé particulièrement notre mère
remplacé donc par un certificat
sanitaire de voyage d'autre part nous
nous et nous nous interrogions sur
l'issue de la cmp jusque là les
sénateurs ou plutôt la droite
sénatoriale n'a pas eu gain de cause
ainsi nous espérons que cette fois et je
les dis dans mon intervention général
monsieur bah tiendra ses positions
notamment sur ces réécritures des
articles phares 1 et 2 pour l'heure et
je veux le dire avec force en
responsabilité ce que nous sommes des
gens responsables des parlementaires
responsables nous pouvons voter un tel
texte sans garantie ni sur les systèmes
d'information ni sur le droit
d'initiative des ultra ultra ma des élus
ultramarins
quant à la mise en oeuvre du certificat
sanitaire de voyages suite à la
saturation des systèmes hospitaliers des
territoires
merci
monsieur président richard
oui monsieur président otayo
merci madame la présidente
ce n'est pas le premier texte sanitaire
qu'on s'apprête à voter très
majoritairement pour notre groupe si
elle 13e
mais c'est le premier
qui fait l'objet d'un examen dans cet
hémicycle dans une nouvelle donne
politique et parlementaire
le sénat comme à l'habitude a fait son
travail faut-il rappeler que le texte
qui nous est arrivé
était un moignon de texte amputé d'une
grosse partie de sa consistance
il est arrivé amputé va repartir
compléter et réécrit très profondément
je voudrais remercier la commission des
lois philippe bas notre excellent
rapporteur du travail qui l'ont fait
tout au long de cette réécriture de cet
examen
le sénat a poursuivi sa ligne sa méthode
habituelle qui est une méthode
d'exigence
l'exigence de clarté nous avons mis
explicitement fin au régime d'exception
pour
les états d'urgence sanitaire
un régime et surtout une exigence aussi
en matière de maîtrise contrôle du
parlement
ça sera pas le gouvernement qui aura le
bon vouloir de décidé de réintégrer ou
non les personnels soignants il ya un
dispositif qui est créé
exigences aussi en matière de maîtrise
des frontières j'avais suffisamment à
l'époque pendant la première année
critiquer le gouvernement
de ce paradoxe puisque on ouvrait tout
grand des frontières au moment où on
replace est devant le domicile des gens
des frontières des petites frontières
avec le confinement c'était
incompréhensible
et enfin une exigence aussi pour que le
dispositif soit strictement
proportionnées nous sommes toujours
favorables à la vaccination mais nous
pensons qu'en matière de contamination
le l'instrument le plus robuste c'est le
dépistage c'est donc un message un
message pour le gouvernement
qui de raconter les lurons avec le sénat
et c'est le retour du parlement mais
madame l'invasion se permettez moi de
dire que dans le retour du parlement
c'est aussi le l'affirmation d'un
bicamérisme qui sera désormais plus
équilibrée
c'est le président richard dans la
présidente
nous arrivons au terme d'un débat qui a
été bien mené dans lequel je salue en
particulier la volonté du gouvernement
d'arriver à un texte répondant aux
besoins
poursuivant les objectifs qu'il avait
fixé au départ mais tenant compte dans
le dans le dialogue dans la délibération
des apports de du sénat dans sa
diversité puisque les votes que nous
avons eues sur les différentes
composantes du texte on s'était parfois
contrastée il me semble donc que le
gouvernement et la majorité qui va
s'exprimer ce soir en faveur de ce texte
au sénat ont largement contribué à
aboutir à un texte responsable un texte
efficace et un texte qui peut devenir
applicable dans les jours qui viennent à
l'issue de la commission mixte paritaire
dans le bicamérisme j'ai entendu parfois
des allusions plus ou moins critiques à
ce qui se passait à l'assemblée
nationale il me semble que quand on veut
vraiment légiférer vraiment faire la loi
on est amené à anticiper sur ce que sera
aussi la préoccupation de l'autre
assemblée pour arriver à un accord
équilibré il me semble que c'est ce que
nous avons fait le gouvernement a
largement contribué il me semble donc
que nous sortions nous sortons avec
l'approbation qui va survenir de ce
texte avec une bonne préparation de la
future législation
merci alors donc je l'avais dit j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe l'est républicain sur
l'ensemble du texte a il va être procédé
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
si alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 123 sur l'ensemble du texte de
contenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordés par les sénateurs au
groupe politique est notifiée à la
présidence nombre de votants 342 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 222 pour
l'adoption 189 contre 33 le sénat a
adopté
mais chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine c'est en jeudi 21
juillet à 11h pour le projet de loi
autorisant la ratification des
protocoles du traité de l'atlantique
nord sur l'accession de la république de
finlande et du royaume de suède la
séance est levée
[Musique]